um hey what's going on everybody it's
time
for the thursday after thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast
and uh a very rare video
edition where i actually have a guest i
figure with the new normal
the pandemic and all that i would bring
somebody that just been such a huge fan
of for almost 10 years
we have uh casey matthew from uh from
the gas monkey garage show whatever the
hell was called fast and loud
in his own place uh casey's paint shop
just south of fort worth texas
yep that's where you're at um all right
well welcome to the show thank you so
much for coming on
thanks for having us on um all right i
gotta ask
a number of questions before uh we get
going because i am
a uh i don't know when i got the car bug
i always liked them but just later in
life i think it was moving out here to
the west coast
and then just seeing all of these cars
either that i wanted in high school or
some of them that i drove because things
last so long out here
oh yeah i saw like a pontiac t-1000
which was pontiac's answer to the chevy
chevette
i've seen a couple of those weird ones
right now dude like some of the most
random like who cared about that car
that much to keep that thing going like
do you remember the chevy citation
i remember a citation but i learned how
to drive on a chevette
all right well the citation was one of
the shittiest just weirdest looking cars
that didn't know what it wanted to be it
was sort of a sedan
sort of a hatchback and my buddy had one
and the radio was literally
turned sideways and but the numbers were
still like that so it was
somebody the rumor was that when they
designed the car they forgot
the radio so they just turned it to the
side and slammed it in so
fit yeah wherever it would fit so
anyways through that and getting into
cars and buying an old truck myself i
started watching on discovery all these
channels and then
uh fast and loud came out and i became a
huge
fan of just the whole process everything
from
haggling for the car all the way to when
they finally take it to you
which was to paint the car so i was
wondering um
i have a million questions i guess i
would just start how did you get start
started with one of the coolest jobs i
think ever like restoring cars and
and painting cars and all of that type
of stuff well i grew up in it so my dad
owns a shop and still runs it today
so he uh did more collision with a
little bit of restoration mixed in there
and then as things progressed and my
passion towards the restoration
and the painting you know grew
the collision world just wasn't for me
because it was kind of one of those
things you know you getting a wreck and
you need your car by monday
so it's like you did the best job you
could in time you could and then my ocd
was kicking in and i wanted to do better
well then i was taking too long for my
dad we'd argue and
you know so i moved on so i found
another job and then
uh lied my way into a painter's job
nobody took me serious
as a painter because your dad's not
really yeah my dad said i can paint good
you know nobody takes that [ __ ] serious
right
so worked my way up and then you know
got to the point where my side work that
i was doing
was making more than my job that i was
working so i had to make the decision
was i going to venture out on my own
and do my own thing or stay working
for somebody else and was that when you
were over at uh was that when you were
with your dad
or when uh that was that was a couple
years afterwards because i jumped around
from a couple different body shops after
that trying to make more money and go to
like bigger shops so like i worked at a
cadillac dealership for a while
and that kind of thing doing that um so
we
decided to start our own shop uh open
casey's paint shop
17 years ago now i guess and
you've had it that long oh yeah i've had
it before gas monkey
so so gas monkey was just sort of your
side gig while you were getting this
this this paint thing going
your own paint shop going well we were
going for a while so i
i started the shop did well and then did
really bad
as i started learning the business is
very hard you got to put
almost as much into running it as doing
the work and all i want to do is
do the work and i wasn't running the
business side so we
started going broke real quick pulled
back out
um bought a house sold everything that i
had i had a
cadillac 49 sedan net had a super duty
we built
and a couple other things sold all the
cars bought a house built a shop went
back to work for another shop
and did that for a while and then ended
up getting burned out
and decided i was gonna go work for
coca-cola and paint cars
only i was like i'm just gonna paint for
people i'm not gonna do any builds we're
not gonna do anything
and um kind of got in the rhythm of
working with gas monkey a little bit in
there
this was at my other shop prior to
closing it down and moving to the house
and i painted a couple cars for richard
i've known erin since we were in
uh high school so i got the beard that
was like a meal dude i haven't seen that
since high school
it blew my mind and forget like how
he's got such a jawline man you don't
see it whenever he's got that
you almost forget it's been like 10
years hey
just out of curiosity why is there never
enough time
you guys always seem like you're up
against it i know part of it's the drama
when they put on a reality show
but i just feel like you're building
these cars for people that obviously
have money
and it's always like i gotta get this
card done by thursday and i always think
or else what the guy doesn't want it
anymore
i mean yeah you're working on the thing
for [ __ ] a year or whatever how long
it is
yeah like what is it about like when you
you were doing your shot because i think
there's a lot of people that have gotten
inspired by guys like you
and they want to start their own shop so
when you what were some of the pitfalls
like
you're like okay i'm gonna paint cars i
know what i'm gonna charge
and then you're painting cars you're
busy as hell but on the other side
you're looking like holy [ __ ] i'm going
broke
like how how did that happen that
was working you you weren't like you
weren't charging enough money or
mine yeah and i think where i learned my
lesson the most was
quoting jobs it's extremely hard to
quote a job for somebody when you're
restoring a car
because over the course of time they
change their mind
or you come into a fork in the road and
it's like hey you know we ran into this
problem we've got to address it do we go
this way or this way
and when you quote something the
customer's got that number in your head
so if you tell them yeah
you're looking at 20 grand
hypothetically right and then
you get to 20 grand and they're
wondering why their car is not done it's
like well you just
six months ago you added thirty thousand
dollars worth of [ __ ] and just you know
you
up your budget but didn't allow to pay
me anymore
so we finally broke through and as we
kind of grew with the show and talking
other shops
realized that that's the worst thing you
can do is just bid a job and
and really nobody in the industry that i
would
and by no means am i discrediting
anybody but i would say the bigger
reputable shops
charge by the hour so we're 75 dollars
an hour
and at that point i don't care how many
times you change your mind you know
you know then you can decide you want
this motor well that you know i
got a bonus check i want to do this
motor well then it's not
in their head it's like well it's just
an easy swap you know
as i say just out of curiosity what kind
of person
thinks like mid job
that that they're gonna not only change
the engine they're gonna add a bigger
one
more powerful that's not gonna be more
money and then what if you already
ordered that other engine
it's on the way what are you supposed to
do with that just take this
i don't even know how much those [ __ ]
things weigh but let's just take it back
it's like we've got it out of the box
and mounted it and i don't want anymore
what i'm not gonna eat the parts but
they think you can just magically put it
back in the wrapper and take it back to
the store and they're gonna be like oh
cool you installed it yeah we'll take it
back
because you live in texas and there's so
much room out there do you have enough
room
to go for a walk on your property when
people do [ __ ] like that to cool off
we just shoot guns and blow stuff up
that's a big yeah how did you um
um i'm also guessing another thing that
i always i think that i gravitated
towards what you're doing the fact that
the fact i thought you were really funny
um
on the show was you seemed like you were
also a ford guy
where you know you you have that that
amazing that frankenstein f100 that you
had
and then you had a car that i had never
heard of it was a ford custom line
yeah it looked like ford's answer maybe
to like the bel air
yeah it was the custom line they're all
kind of like fairlane based
but then they had a couple different
models just like the bell air head
you know uh bel air 210
you know all that kind of stuff so 210
was the entry level and then the bel air
was
the higher one the top so like in my
version of the car custom line was kind
of mid-grade they had a main line
and then they had the crown vic which
the crown vic was the bel air
of ford so has anybody done sort of the
mob
family tree of of cars where
what i what i've been told by car guys
is back in the day
you know everybody now will make an
entry-level car like mercedes will have
a car like a college student could
afford and back in the day
if you drove a mercedes that meant you
made it so like
right with gm cadillac was the top
then it was like buick then it was
something like oldsmobile pontiac and
then down to chevy
is there any way to find because i
remember as a kid
you know when that was starting to get
phased out but i still remember with
like the camaro
there was the rally sport then there was
the berlinetta
and then there was the z28 the firebird
had the regular fiber the formula 400
and then the trans am
um is there anything out there where if
you're sort of a nerd for that stuff
like myself that you can read up on
because i always get confused like with
saying like a desoto or packard were
they part of ford
gm or chrysler were they their own thing
right
man there's so many car companies that
have been out there manufacturers that
have come and gone in the past too like
packard like that was an
awesome place i've been to the packard
plant up in uh detroit and that's just
that's a really neat place
in shambles now unfortunately but yeah i
mean all those
i'm sure there is you know i've never
looked into it just
you kind of zone in on what you're
you're hot about you know with
us it's ford trucks so um
i haven't really gone down the road of
doing that much much research
i guess as far as like the tree of
all right so are you still are you just
painting strictly right now just
painting
no we do full restorations for you y'all
so you do all of that stuff so do you do
all of that too and then paint it
yeah i've got three guys that work for
me full time uh
well two guys and a girl that worked for
me full time and i've got a part-time
helper
at the first of the year i actually um
shifted the direction i guess you could
save the shop and and let the entire
shop go
and then refresh because i was kind of
losing the
the passion for it getting a little beat
down the way things were going i was
having a hard time
doing some things i was moving the shops
to construction and everything else so
now we're in our new shop
hired some guys that have been around
for a while and uh been buddies
you kind of hung around did work with me
but never worked for me type thing
and then keenan came back um so we've
got a really good crew now but we do
full restorations from
from ground up the only thing we don't
do is interior work
well i know in stand up whenever i get
burned out which does you know happens
like
you know some of it's be just because of
the travel and then other times it's
just
you know your act just slows down and
it's like god i'm so sick of these jokes
and then you feel this guilt because you
got the responsibility for the acts you
gotta
with it for the crowd you gotta uh
figure out a way to get excited
are there cars i don't wanna get you in
trouble here but are there cars that
roll in
where you're like oh god i gotta redo
another one of these like uh
yeah there are i kind of found i felt
like when i was watching some of those
shows
that almost like a hacky topic for a
stand-up
i kind of felt like mustangs were
were done like everybody had one of
those as opposed to
those and camaros and everything yeah
yeah i kind of feel like all those
muscle cars because i
i've i've had two cars built
and um one i'm finishing right now so i
don't want to tell people what it is but
like
i was sitting there nervous to call the
guy
i got this thing built for my dad he had
a 59 four-door hard top
uh chevy impala white with red interior
and um it was a really rare car
as far as it didn't have that that sort
of fastback it was more of a straight
and went down like that
and when i called my guy up like
he almost did a backflip because he was
like oh my god i would love to work on
that car and i kind of got the vibe from
him
anything but yet another mopar another
thing that isn't a shelby trying to be a
shelby
it seems like um i kind of got to ask
you i kind of got bored watching some of
that mecum
thing because we've got another road
runner coming up it's just like how many
times can i watch
the same uh makes them the same they
clone them all
you know they'll they'll clone the 500s
you know it's not a real car but it
looks like one and all that stuff too so
you kind of get bored of seeing it but
as a builder for me i mean i like
topping the last build so
trucks all together i'm in on any truck
just about
what's your favorite uh what's some of
your favorite builds you've done
recently
um i'm extremely happy with my green
truck we just rebuilt
um that was wait what what was wrong
with that thing
you gave me a ride in that and i don't
think the camera worked i was
here trying to be cool just going like i
know this guy doesn't want to kill him
kill me or kill himself you went down
that that road when i was out in dallas
i was doing a show and i got to ride in
that now famous truck
and you got me by the end i had my feet
up on the dashboard like
i mean that your trucks faster than that
yeah when you rode in and played it
about 600 or so at the wheels
and now it does a little over a thousand
at the wheels
but it but it's a different truck before
it was just explain that to listeners
and to me
at the wheels because i know you lose
some horsepower with the whole
combustion going through so there's uh
crank horsepower which was is horsepower
measured at the flywheel
and then you lose a certain percentage
of horsepower at the crank
by time you go through the transmission
drive shaft rear end and through the
wheels
so putting a thousand of the wheels is
probably
somewhere in the 1150 crank horsepower
so it's a substantial amount of power
but
it's full chassis built i mean it's
what did you have to modify on that
truck so when you
stomped on it it didn't literally just
flip over
it uh getting the power to weight ratio
was
was hard getting the weight ratio of the
car is hard too
especially on a truck because you want
to try to get as equally balanced as you
can
so if you have all the weight in the
front or all the way in the back you go
to hit the brakes
and it weighs too much in the back you
can push in the corners so a good 50 50
weight ratio is always nice so
what what do you do like on a truck
where like so much of the weight is up
front
the back end's just a bed what do you
have to put back there
we try to put a big fuel cell in the
back so like my truck's got a custom
built tank in the back behind the rear
end
so that we get as much weight on the
back side of the axle as possible just
like the motor is usually up front on
the front driveline
center so move that back batteries to
the back
that kind of thing so when you start to
get lower on fuel do you find the thing
gets more squirrely
or is it not that noticeable it's not
super noticeable
um not not so much that you would be
worried about it
i guess you could say you basically have
to be like a test pilot in aviation you
put you put this monster engine in there
now so when you go down the street you
obviously don't want to screw up what
you just built
so what do you go at like 60 percent oh
i get it
i give it all of it right to the floor
i built it to go all out so it's just
everything she's got every time i play
with it
i don't want to jinx you but have you
ever taken somebody's car out
just to to test something like that and
ended up
uh hitting something or getting into a
uh an act
never no but i'll call you what i do and
cuss you out for sure for no no no i
don't i don't want to do that but
um all right so i gotta ask this this is
another
uh fanboy question here how do you do a
burnout
if you've never done one and you don't
end up on youtube
as that guy who thinks he's spinning his
wheels but he's actually burning out his
clutch
just smoking the clutch yeah i guess it
kind of depends
you know is it a manual transmission
automatic it's
not a matter just hit the brake in the
gas at the same time and
put it to the floor and if you've got
enough power you'll break it loose if
you don't you just look like a chump
and then mail transmissions on a stick
how do you do it on a stick
duh because i'm afraid i'm afraid i'm
gonna
burn out the clutch of my truck it's
it's more difficult because you
you've got a what they call a heel toe
so you got to use your heel
to hold the brake and then use your toe
to to work the gas while you're working
the clutch you still got to kind of do
the same thing
it's just oh so it is the same thing
yeah or
you can just rev it to the moon and dump
the clutch and slam on the brake i've
seen guys do that do you see their cars
jump five feet and then stop and then
just depends how you want to look like
my charge got a line lock on it so if i
were to go to the track you press the
brake
activate the solenoid it holds all the
pressure to the front wheels
and releases the back and then you can
just let the clutch out and it will go
and then you just flip the switch off it
releases the solenoid and gets your
you know releases the brakes at that
point all right another question i've
always wanted to ask you
do what do you think about rats are
those
uh so like in the paint world when they
look at that because there's some pretty
crazy reps and you look at them and you
spent all this money took the car apart
um
what is in the paint community what are
you guys thinking about those things
i think they have their place i think on
some of the newer cars that
if you want maybe obviously
for advertising they have their place
you know you wrap your car with whatever
it is you know that for advertising but
you know there's some things that
you can do with some of those wraps that
won't hurt the paint
you know versus in value too right so
you wrap your car but you want to get
rid of it in five years but you've
changed the color you devalue it you
know because everybody wants that clean
carfax
and they'll wonder why the car is
wrapped so i've seen a lot of these guys
especially exotic cars that want to
change the color to be a little
different than the other guy
that they'll wrap them in matte colors
and pearlescent films and
whatever and i mean they don't bother me
i mean they're expensive i can't believe
how much it costs you know some of those
things i know i just
right before this right before the
pandemic
uh i i put a clear wrap on my jaguar
just because
sometimes it sits in the sun and i
didn't want the paint to fade and all of
that type of stuff so it's still the
same color
um but uh it's it's kind of amazing now
though where if if somebody were to sort
of
rub up against it they can't scratch the
paint so that's like a cool thing
when you do one of those custom paint
jobs uh
are there way more coats than what what
the factory
uh paint was or does it all depend on
the customer what they're looking for
we pretty much do the same thing on
every car so we'll
what we call file it and check for
highlights through the car so
what your eye might see is flat you know
when you put a light next to it you'll
see
the ripples in the paint because of the
light so usually
we'll run lights down the side of the
car and make sure that we wet it down
it's all
smooth so when we put clear coat on it
we'll file that down the same way
we usually do between five and six coats
of clear on a car
but by the time we get done wet sanding
it to buff it's probably brought it down
to about
two maybe two and a half coats of clear
stains so much off and more clear
doesn't necessarily build that up to
give you to
to fix all those imperfections yeah we
can move
the line around and everything like that
so it helps
the fact that you put so much on but
aftermarket clear coats
are very i guess advanced in a way too
right so
it doesn't take as much clear for the uv
protection as people would think
and that's just the misconception people
think oh the more the better
not necessarily the more film builds you
get just like anything else right like
if you uh
the more film build the more brittle it
can get to so you put ten coats of clear
on a car and get a rock chip it can
blister
easier than two coats because it won't
have the flex because you'll hit
something
is it all stuff that you've just learned
through the years and people drive the
car back and then you're like ah [ __ ] i
gotta do this all over again
i kind of i kind of tech out a little
bit on that so i'm really
we use a basf paints so i like talking
to the reps
and the guys that are the chemists that
are working with it so i i try to stay
on the leading edge of
all of that to know like what is a good
film build and we check our film build
as we're painting too
so we'll know if we put on too much or
if we're going to have problems because
more club more coats of clear you do if
the bottom doesn't dry before the top
tops what they call like a skim over
then the bottom side will actually react
and give you solvent pop and can ruin
your paint job so what is the technique
when you go to spray it on it's not like
some kid just coloring in when
when you got to be like a certain
distance how do you stop it from like
dripping in like practice
huh practice yeah i use good guns too
did your dad make you like i don't know
have like a piece of plywood
and just working he must have had you do
that before he actually had you
like what was the training before you
actually
sat down i'm thinking like a barber
where they have like a balloon and they
like make you do the straight razors
mine was more let me fail i think i
learned more from my mistakes than i do
being taught
i'm i learn a lot better when somebody
just lets me do it and mess up
because i you know i almost feel like i
get nervous when people are trying to
teach you too much
because it's hard to process it so over
the years i've learned a lot
by screwing up then i have talking to
people you know you taking the
information you read all the tech sheets
you kind of know what you're supposed to
do but those are
generally shot at like 70 degrees right
well sometimes we're 95 or 100 degrees
in my booth so that tech sheet really
doesn't mean [ __ ]
you know it's like how do you have to
adjust that
most of the times like a drag so we'll
put a coat of clear on
and then we can fingerprint it like
we'll wait till it starts stringing a
little bit
and then we'll put our second one on and
then depending on the temperature and
humidity outside we'll add a little bit
of time per coat
so like my first coat between my first
and second coat might be 15 minutes
but between my fourth and fifth might be
45 minutes or an hour
because you're trying to let it gas out
you know get the um solvents out of it
so you don't entrap them
underneath everything that's that that's
what blows my mind like people just
think oh you paint cars like this
you know nothing to it like you're
coloring in something and like
the level of science that is involved in
this
and then also i also love people that
start their own businesses
and i follow you on instagram so i'm
always seeing you you're going to like
these
these car shows uh recently you i think
the last one i saw you going to like
orange beach or something in in
alabama was that right so
how how important is that for people
starting off with like a shop
to have um you know to be at all of
these shows
i would assume that if there's a local
car show if you're starting out you're
small
you want to be there set up a booth meet
people and then
it's almost i swear it's so much like
comedy where you just start in your town
get to know all the club owners and then
all of a sudden
you're trying to like go national how
many of those do you hit
as far as uh during a normal year
uh 10 to 12 we try to do maybe
one a month maybe more depending on the
distance of them you know the farthest
we've gone away
um what is it uh
didn't you go all the way out to
jacksonville one time or something yeah
we've gone to des moines
we've got we've gone a lot of places and
i mean there's
there's good and bad with all that right
so i mean we're we're booked we're busy
so if you do too many shows i feel like
it can almost be just as bad for you to
go out and say you're too busy
it's like well don't go to casey he's
got too much [ __ ] going on so i think
there's got to be equal balance of how
much you want to put yourself out there
because if you advertise for work and
work and work and they just keep telling
everybody you can't do it sooner or
to keep because if we go l advertise or
we do a lot on social media
we get a lot of emails well the more
emails you get
and you keep telling hey we're 18 months
or 12 months or 24 months out
most people are instant gratification
seekers so
they're going to go to the next shop so
it's
i guess i'm more looking towards like a
steady
group of people to to do work for and so
we do a lot of work
we have a lot of reworks like cars will
go out and then the customer
they like to build process so they'll
send another car so we kind of got some
clients to just build one car after
another and they just
keep doing which those are great
but advertising is good and bad you know
i'm sure you've been there too it's like
you do too much it's almost two months
you do too little then you're
watching i had a dream last night
that i i was watching myself on an
interview that i didn't remember doing
and i had a panic attack
oh my god i'm putting myself out there
too much because that that is definitely
a thing in my business it's weird with
like podcasting because this is just
sort of like a weekly show type of thing
so even though i'm putting myself out
there with that it's not the same thing
i i feel anyway as far as like
if if you do um i have a thing in my
business where
i try to always avoid ever going on a
show
unless i have something there's a reason
i'm there like you know i got five lines
in a movie they want me to come on and
sell the movie you know obviously i i
gotta do that but like um
that's stuff where i call it extra tv
where it's like hey you want to be not
like i've ever been offered this but
like um
you know if you've already been out
there and you did the whole promotional
circuit
and then like uh one of these game shows
hey we're doing a uh podcast host
you know dude or whatever you know
not like you're flattered it's like you
want to be asked but like that's one of
those things where you really have to
sit there and think going like
all right is this going to be like a
cool thing you know i go on there
anything i win it's for charity so
that's a good thing
but is it i just don't want to have that
person at home going if i have to look
at this [ __ ] guy's
goddamn bald head again which is
everything that everybody's now gonna
write underneath this uh you almost want
people to
want more of you instead of always
seeing you
like how can we don't see more uh you
know this or why don't we see more of
that
yeah like oh yeah he's just always there
yeah and that's he's on the next thing
we'll see him next week on another show
you know it's like you want to be almost
seeked out more than you want to be just
the norm yeah i've learned a lot about
that watching how chris rock does it and
the beastie boys
back in the day watching them where they
would they could play the game
so good i mean chris i would see just
because i was a comedian but i was
saying just as far as like seeing him in
a movie or tv
he they they had like that perfect
timing of
of this there's a thing where you want
them to like man where are they
and then but if it goes too far this way
then they forget about you and they
always
seem to know right when like oh [ __ ]
they're bad i better do something
special all right all right the beastie
boys dropped a new album and then they
would do like a tour
and then when the tour was done they
would come on letterman they would play
whatever the song sabotaged back in the
day and then they would do the tour
and then just gone and then right half
four years right where you
right as you started to think are they
gonna put out something else it was bam
there was the next one
and the uh the next tour so um you want
to be known as more of the elite
you know it's like you pick the right
gigs and that's
we do that with the shop like not that
we like tell people we don't want to
work on their cars
but i do this because i want to do it
it's a passion yeah i don't want to get
burned out on it
so i want to do cars for people that
have the same passion than i do about
the car
i don't want to do it for some guy that
just
just has money doesn't know what to do
with this he just tells you to build
something doesn't really care about the
car doesn't have any plans for the car
it's going to sit in his garage nobody
sees it it doesn't do me any good to put
all of my heart and soul into something
that's going to sit in somebody's garage
and it's never seen like i get it made
money but that's not advertising
you know so if you're doing big cars you
want them to be out and be seen
yeah that's another thing i don't get
about making this one they'll be like
this is an
all original matching number blah blah
blah the car is like 50 years old and it
has 2 000 miles on it
and i always think like what was what is
the purpose
of owning that car there's a mercedes
benz i always forget
what it literally looks like remember
that show speed racer
oh yeah way back when it has like a has
a really long hood
long nose yeah long nose and you're
literally riding like you need
goggles like kanye west had one it or i
don't know if you still say one of those
beautiful cars
i've ever seen and they had one of those
for sale on one of these shows
and it was like you know like that car's
like at this point like 10 years old 12
years old however long they made them
and this thing had like 1500 miles on it
and i'm just thinking like
the car's like a million bucks or
something crazy like that some crazy
astronomical number
and it's like you never even took it out
to like the track
because i get like okay i'm gonna spend
a million dollars on a freaking car and
i'm gonna drive down the street some
[ __ ] and a prius me
is gonna [ __ ] t-bone me and then be
like ah
sorry sorry about that um
i kind of get that but uh i've never
understood
um i hate to keep going back to the show
you were on but like i remember
when uh they went out and they bought a
um
a ferrari that had a bent frame and i
distinctly remember aaron or somebody
saying like
uh f40 yeah when you buy a ferrari
this is what it should look like like
you should drive this thing i mean
obviously you don't want to wreck it
but in a way i actually respected the
person
that wrecked it more than the person
that keeps it pristine
owns it for 20 years and then shows and
he's got 800 miles on it
it hurts me on that kind of thing
because it's like these cars are no
investment
i mean not for like i could see like the
crazy bentleys and one of one and a
collection of
you know these are they only made three
those have a certain point
i guess that they they might keep going
up or whatever right
um with me none of that really matters i
guess
you know some people have their niche
right like they want that car that's
what they're after
somebody could bring me a matching
numbers one of one
69 copo hey i want you to put on a
chassis big brakes you ain't the motor
[ __ ] yeah i'd yank all that [ __ ] out and
throw in the scrap bin it doesn't matter
to me like
i'm all about now how did you get to
that because
i always um like with my truck
you know i mean i used to make money in
this business but when i had money
there was definitely a temptation to do
to it
a little bit i mean not what you did i
mean i i couldn't i don't have the skill
set to drive yours but like
there was definitely a there was some
things that i maybe wanted to do to make
it a little bit faster
but i was uh i bought the truck it was
just so all original
i didn't want to mess with it and i and
it shifts on the column which i thought
was the coolest thing ever
and everything was gonna when i was like
is there any way to five-speed overdrive
on the column
the six-speed manual on the car shifting
up and down the whole time
coming closer to you or you're like you
got on the other side
you guys like yeah man i don't know if i
could do that so uh is that something
you always had just
not a sentimental person or you just
know how to make it better or
i guess i'm sentimental in the fact of
like i've had my green truck since i was
like i was late 14 early 15 years old
when i got
that green truck to start with so like
i've never gotten rid of
it you know in the title on it it was in
my mom's names i was too young to have a
title
you know in my name and then it's my
name now so it's like my mom's name that
was sold to me so like that's
sentimental
but as far as like the parts or whatever
like i want to get in my
vehicles any of them and enjoy them to
the nines so
i feel like like people like oh i'm in
the model a club and i've got this old
model
it's like i get the nostalgic of that in
a way
but it's like you can do 30 you can't
stop
it's hard to steer you got no heat it's
like how enjoyable is it really
to drive around in that where me
i went to the track yesterday with my
truck to the road course
and i'm out running brand new gt350s
running with brand new c8 vets and out
running porsches like
that yeah that's cool [ __ ]
like going down the road
sorry what's it like after the race when
you go up to the guy with the shelby or
something like that
and you're in you just pop callers on
you walk by
and just keep walking like they look at
you like damn it
because they see an old truck they think
i got a brand new porsche i got a brand
new vet
i'm going to kill everybody out here i
just got passed by a truck what the hell
you know and then they're pissed you
just win like mentally you don't say
anything
you just drive off and leave and let
leave them thinking but those are the
kind of guys that come to you
how do i make mine as fast as yours and
then you make money
so i went out there not only you have
the power but and then i would think
like
because you don't have all that [ __ ] in
the back is that what keeps it lighter
it's full chassis so it's a roaster shop
chassis it's all
ca uh c6 corvette geometry on the front
so it handles like a brand new car it's
it's absolutely
absurd i mean the back tires are 345
it's all racing tires all the way around
what can i do with my truck because when
i take a turn at like
even like 10 miles an hour i literally
have to reach under the seat don't slide
into the door
uh man start by uh lowering that dude a
little bit
those pictures you send me it's like
that far off there i mean
i thought it was i thought it was four
wheel drive i wasn't sure
i have a thing with uh
lowered trucks i mean if they look like
yours
that's one thing but like um
i just feel like it's a truck you know
what i mean it's it's like
it should be a truck so there's nothing
i can do there's not a sway bar
or or update that you could add a sway
bar to the front of it
i think uh i think those trucks had an
option of a sway bar maybe
ah well they're twin i-beam i don't know
if they are or not
one of the few things i actually know
how to do on on a
i just knew how to do basic maintenance
um
but like if i go to change the oil i
don't know you have this on yours mine's
at 68.
the the the drain plug on the oil plan
this piece that that's like part of the
frame so it's going to cut all the oil
is going to come down and go all over
the place
yeah and it killed me because when i got
the truck one of the first things that
went out i bought a uh
an oil filter wrench down at the thing
and i was all excited like you know i
was gonna dress like fonzie with my
little onesie
and get under this thing and basically
just change the oil and um
i was talking to a buddy of mine i was
like why the [ __ ] would they
design it like he said that's just how
it was back then one one whoever was
doing the chassis he wasn't talking to
this guy and then they just put the [ __ ]
together
and that's how that's how it ended up
being yeah um all right
i gotta uh i gotta ask this too okay so
i started to get on
to the topic of uh you know oh my god i
don't i'm gonna paint another one of
these i could literally do this with my
eyes closed
what are your top five favorite cars
that you ever worked on be it like
because you always wanted to work on it
or it was kind of like you know when i
bought the car in from my dad where they
were just like i've never
who the [ __ ] brings a four-door 59
impala in
i would love to redo this car what are
you ready your top five
um
there's you know we blew through them so
fast on the show it was hard to really
even keep track i couldn't even name all
the cars that we did on the show
there was one in the very beginning by
the way did you guys really build them
that fast
yes so we didn't sleep much in the
beginning we were in proving grounds
in a way right so if it was a single
episode
show it was uh two weeks
we had two weeks to build the car and if
it was a double episode like if it was
like see you next week
it was four weeks so generally in the
beginning
it was you know three four days of fab
work
five days maybe and then it would go to
me and i would paint it as fast as i
possibly could and
sometimes i had help and sometimes i
didn't and we would paint them in
four or five days bring them back do
final assembly and be done with them
it was it was terrible but
why now just i think just because of the
stupid tv show
schedule like i think a lot of it had to
do with
us trying to prove that we could do it
so i think that's what made the show
what it was
we set the grounds for doing things that
most people would say
couldn't be done or that um
said could be done and took weeks after
that so like every time we said we're
going to do something we nailed it
and i think the show grew um the
production company
you know grew you know liked it and just
kept buying episodes so
when i was working at coke richard
called me and said hey
we want you to do this show with us and
i was like
all right i thought he was joking
because i know he'd shot a couple pilots
before trying to get a show
and this one stuck so i had like all
right
it's a great story and then the genius
too of that it was called fast and loud
and i'm a fan and i still call it gas
monkey because they would always say
that and they would sell their merch
like
brandon richard's awesome at branding
like he's an incredible businessman
yes so i also like when he would do the
used car
salesman character the gimmick stuff
you can see this guy grew up in this
this is totally like
in his blood yeah for sure so i
had 24 hours to make the call woke up my
wife that night she told me i'd be crazy
if i didn't take the job
uh went down the next morning uh called
the guys at coca-cola
gave him i told him like i'm not coming
in i'm quitting they understood
it was still nuts uh then work to work
work for richard immediately and then
drove to dallas
every day for four and a half five years
or whatever it is
when i worked there i mean it was it was
cool and i don't regret it
it i missed i guess the biggest regret
of the entire thing was the home
you know missing my kids growing up so i
was gone so much that was one of my
favorite episodes when i was then i knew
you were leaving too
yeah you you painted it at your house
and you just seemed like you were
totally at peace
which you don't see on the show because
you know that's part of the drama of the
show with the grind i'm not [ __ ] on
the shop because
uh i i think it's amazing what they do
there but you were you were back
you know sitting on your steps or
something going i miss my kids
and blah blah blah blah and there's a
comic i was relating to that where
there wasn't a question yeah there was a
point in my career where i got so busy
and you know i'm selling tickets then it
just becomes like
well what is the point of this because i
was like walking to do
shows and i would see you know boyfriend
girlfriend husbands and wife sitting out
having dinner
on a friday night and i was feeling
these feelings of like
i would [ __ ] love to do that right
now yeah
and then you feel like who the [ __ ] am i
to be thinking that as i'm walking
to this comedy club where everybody
bought these tickets they they would
love to do this so i was like all right
i know i have an awesome job obviously
so i need to find
more of like a balance so when you
left the show to do your own paint shop
but when aaron left the show
um i i was like
you know as a fan i'm like [ __ ] i want
to keep seeing those guys
their chemistry is amazing amazing but
then it's just as far as someone who
travels and is away from home
i was actually like happy for you guys
and um
oh speaking of aaron isn't he doing like
i i thought i saw something on the
internet where he was doing something
where
he was going to be making uh parts for
f-100s am i crazy
no so they worked on uh
like uh where they called like slick
side trucks so like early 60s so call it
like
60 was it 61
of four or whatever the straight at what
makes it slick side i don't know what
that means they kind of make like uh
so the body lines are more swooping so
they they're kind of known as the slick
side
and then my truck and your truck are
known as bump side because of the bump
on the side
and 73 to 79 they kind of curved in so
they call them dead sides
so they've all kind of got like square
body chevys you know people call them
square bodies but they were like 73 to
86 or whatever chevy trucks and they've
all kind of got their little
nicknames that people call them but he
made a kit
for those that changed the geom it
lowered it and changed the geometry of
the steering because straight axles
are known for being like you get death
while we're going on the highway
so he made some brackets and kind of
bends beams and does little things in
the front to get the geometry right so
you can get that
going down the highway i need to know
this because i'm sure you get
a death wobble so with a straight axle
truck the steering's connected and it's
all on one so you kind of get to where
the wheels will
jump off of each other if you don't have
the uh
the right angle so the more was it
caster
you get you like when you turn your
wheel and you let go in your car and it
kind of corrects itself
yeah because your center line is laid
back
and that causes the wheels to correct
themselves
well whenever the caster is too straight
up
you can get to where that wheel isn't
being forced
straight they're kind of they'll get
where they're jumping around on you
so he changes the caster angle or the uh
that's that's beyond my uh
well you know what i uh flying
helicopters there's a thing
that can happen called uh ground
resonance
where uh i i can't this is from ground
squad i can't remember
i've just seen this these people there's
somehow something goes on with it when
they set down
with the way they're setting down and
what's going on where i i can't i
already forget
this is embarrassing how it happens but
literally you sat down and the thing
starts shaking now you should lift up
but they it people freak out they don't
happen the little thing just shakes and
falls apart
like uh the cops car and smoking in the
bandit
yeah and i've seen that also with like
motorcycles
with where they they they start doing
like this thing
there's a great video scary video of a
guy on instagram
starts having that happen and he's on
the highway and there's a
tractor-trailer
right next to him he goes down like a
stunt and
slides underneath the [ __ ] truck
and he's like in jeans so it's like the
momentum he got road rash but he didn't
get squashed i don't know how
how it happened and he got up he's like
he's all ripped up and bloody but he's
like
it's all right i'm alive i'm alive like
that's how it ends and it's just like
that right there
is why i would never [ __ ] ride a
motorcycle so
um all right so let's uh
let's talk your website here um so it's
casey's paint shop.squarespace.com
is that is that right that's the way it
came up no
i don't know [ __ ] i think it's just
casey's paint shop.com
i think it yeah andrew you got to help
me out here i looked it up
it's i thought it was casey's paint
shop.com and then it says squarespace
you have to get the work done let alone
try to learn how to run a website i
don't know
i know how to like call my cell phone
and like it's casey
you're right he's paint shop.com but
when you go there it redirects to the
squarespace but it's oh it goes to the
square store or whatever
oh but no he uh he had it right
all right well just out of curiosity for
somebody who would want you
to paint a car that they're actually
going to drive and uh
risk you know smash it off yeah like
how how far like my next car that i want
to get
um i want to get a 67 cadillac eldorado
and there's a couple of colors that they
had that year there's one that's
between uh a gray and a blue
that is jus it's just one of the most
beautiful cars i've ever seen in my life
and it's really
my style where uh i am not a
going fast guy as you know giving me a
ride in your truck i know dude
yeah but you need guys like me so guys
like you seem cool
you got to have the guys like me out
there so we gotta have to go into teas
[Laughter]
no dude like if i could just have that
car and smoke a cigar and drive down the
[ __ ] street at the end of all of this
touring around telling jokes you know my
kids turn out to be decent human beings
like i'm um you know my wife stays with
me i'm done that's all i need so
if i if i were to get this car i don't
want to put you in a corner i can edit
this out here but how far are you backed
up
um right now for like a full build we're
probably
over a year probably right if i just
want to get it painted if i have
somebody else
and you paint it uh it kind of depends
on where we were in line right you know
for the body shop because
if our fab shop if we do a good job of
the fab shop body shop goes quick and
sometimes we
are looking for fill-in work but
something like that wouldn't take very
long to paint it'd just be the matter of
taking it apart painting and putting it
back together for you right
so um
man just be one of those that's almost a
case by case really in a way just
depends on where the shop is at the
point you know like if we get
them on a day like that i'm seeing a lot
of daylight because one of my
i gotta have you at some point something
that i get i gotta have you paint it
because
i was sold on your stuff uh when you did
that lace top
oh yeah some sort of white car or
something he did that lace top i thought
that was like the perfect car to do that
on
and it was like your idea and then i
also liked
how after a while you got annoyed by
putting clear
on a patina car it was just
i just felt like you felt like you were
the invisible man looks like they wanted
to see us paint something i'm like you
know we're not doing [ __ ] right but just
putting clear we're not painting
anything but they wanted to see us doing
something
right and it almost seemed like then it
for there's like a short stint there
that we did it a lot
and i was getting burned out and i was
like
we don't have to do this [ __ ] like i
just soon not do it at all
you know we don't like the clear made
the whatever the
chemistry of the rust made that stop no
it doesn't no so like after a couple
years of clear coating one of those
um we've had a couple that we've seen
that the rust keeps growing
underneath it and it turns the rust
white under the bottom side of it
because it's almost
you're not really stopping anything the
only way to kill rust is to neutralize
it which uses the blaster to chemically
you know neutralize the rust putting
clear on it just
kind of oh i thought it did i thought it
looks this is once again my poor science
back it looks cool for a while
but it comes off there was no oxygen to
be able to like you sealed it off like a
sandwich it would stay
you would just cryo cryofreeze it no
i did a couple trucks a couple years ago
we did a 49 ford
and a 53 chevy we took the sema three
four years ago now
and uh we just scotch-brited them really
good cleaned them up and kind of gave
them like a sheen
and then if you wash them i mean rust
needs moisture
and stuff to grow anyway so as long as
you just take care of it it usually
doesn't get any worse
you know if it's cleaned off where you
have the biggest problem is whenever
like the dirt is inside the quarter
panels and you know when it gets wet it
stays wet for
a week or whatever that's what's bad so
we just quit doing it and if people
watch their car normally don't rub
off on them so we just we've got a 64
that
the customer actually came today to
drive for the first time in
two years we've been building this truck
for them and uh it's a 15 a truck and we
just cleaned it and
it's good so maybe that's not clear
maybe that's i'll just find something
that i can just deal with that i don't
have
and just drop it off and then i'll see
you in a couple of years and and
let me know when it's done yeah
well i like weird [ __ ] so i hope
whatever i bring that i
if i ever if i ever work again as a
comedian casey all right i plan
i plan on uh bringing you something at
some point so
uh how about we wrap up with uh you
telling people where they can
what's what's the next um big event that
you're gonna be out at your once a month
thing
you got anything i mean can they even
have those things right now
we just got a notification today that do
you know what sema is
no sema it's a special equipment
manufacturer association i think that's
right um
huge show that's in vegas every year um
usually around halloween right after
halloween that it's
it's massive so it's like all the
manufacturers come together and it's
just a place where you can go and learn
everything about the new stuff coming
out for the next year and usually
for the past seven years or so we build
a car
and you debut it at that show so that's
where my green truck was built last year
and it was uh put the basf booth which
is our paint company that we use
which is it was a huge deal to me being
a painter and having a car paint booth
is
that is a hard gig to get yeah so i was
extremely excited to be in there
uh but they canceled it so uh we haven't
been to a show this year yet and i don't
know if we're gonna do it
i think we're just gonna probably take
the rest of the year off and see
in 2021 you know i don't really know
what else to do
starting to think that that's where i'm
at we're toying with an idea
of possibly doing something back
east then i gotta i gotta figure out how
am i gonna get there
and and you know i mean i got a brand
new baby boy at home it's like then what
i'm gonna do that gig and then come back
and quarantine for 14
freaking days it is it is a crazy time
but um
i don't know i guess hopefully you know
in 2021 when we're all working again
i hope i can hit you up with some some
sort of weird vehicle
i should have made a list of some of the
[ __ ] that i like it's a lot of like
just uh i don't know i mean i like those
old man
uh executive cars from the 70s
oh yeah i'd like those uh to like
cab over you know coes those those
things and um
ceo these are fun they're cool cars yeah
and i kind of left all the muscle cars
but i feel like that was like a high
school phase
and and i feel like those are sort of
baby boomer cars in a way where it's
like
that's the car they wanted when they
were in high school so then that's their
dream to get it i get that
where i think i kind of look at like you
know what are those early 80s like
monte carlo's oldsmobiles and buick
eagles
you're coming in hot man like we're
restoring a 93
mustang cobra right now for a guy um
i mean that's like i'm i'm 37
right so we've got cars that i wanted in
high school i drove a lot of fox bodies
well now guys that are my age that
wanted those or had those when they were
younger and starting to make some money
it's weird seeing the emails that we're
getting now about restoring
late 80s early 90s cars and trucks and
you're like that's not that
because i still drive a 95 lightning
every day
so to me 95 is not old i just drive my
lighting
and people like hey can you restore this
i'm like restore it i got two of them
you want to sell you one of these you
know but they're like
i want to restore pristine and you don't
think that's 30
years old already you know it's like wow
man
i guess one that i like uh the best
truck i think of the last
20 years well i like that that dodge
hemi
the 1500 short bed yeah um before they
messed up that i don't like their front
ends right now
the little rt trucks they had a little
faster enemies or whatever yeah
yeah there was i liked it and there was
a blue that they had that i liked and
there was a black and i was wondering
so classic me if i get that thing i
don't want to take the hemi out it's the
original engine and all of that
something like that what would you do
with that thing what was your first idea
if you want to make like first of all
like
when you look at that truck what are
your feelings of it i mean as far as
coming straight from the factory the
power and all of that
do you respect it you're good that's one
uh me and my wife are talking my son
just turned 14 so we're looking to
buy him something and uh probably next
year or so because i want to be able to
tinker with it a little bit i don't want
to restore anything for them
but if we could tinker with something i
was like you know those dodgers are
reasonably priced
you know dodge doesn't really hold their
value very well anyway so
you know getting one of those lower it
you know put some exhaust on just kind
of make it need some nice wheels i mean
it's already got power when is it locks
and what else do you do to it really
you know except throw your i'm saying
would you would you mess with the engine
at all or no
oh yeah twin turbos all down really i
i can't leave anything alone as far as
motor goes they're never fast enough
so or maybe when i get out there if you
teach me how to drive faster maybe i'll
i'll
i'll uh i'll bring you something fast
but i'm probably going to bring your
grandpa cars
you're going to bring me a dodge truck
and want me to put a prius motor in or
something
don't do that yes i had a prius for nine
years they're [ __ ] amazing
don't don't even start with it i will i
will defend that car
to the end of the as far as like for
what it does
see what does it do tell me what it does
all right
what it does do you ever have a friend
in your life that never needs anything
never [ __ ] and always has you back
and always there for you
that's what the okay don't have one
that's what the prius is no matter how
bad the gas prices got
i like i would i was always under 40
bucks dude i live in l.a there's no
place to drive fast unless i want to
like
you know do a line of coke at three in
the morning and then jump on the highway
but even then
they're going to be doing construction
and slow everybody down right no
and then when gas prices were cheap i
would be filling that thing up and i
would be laughing at the pump
it's like i would pay what i paid in
high school for my [ __ ] car for gas
so
um in defense of the prius they never
said that they would line up with your
frankenstein truck okay they just
you know i'm gonna send you this picture
and you're gonna laugh
are you so my brother-in-law
has a uh or had a prius
it's you're describing exactly how it
was i gave him he
worked at my hot rod shop for two years
and he drove a gold prius
and i made him park around the corner
it's like don't park that front a shop
it's terrible then we would get to where
we're taking it somewhere because it's
like he's like dude
it won't take gas we'll just go or
whatever and then prices gas
shot up and like they had a shortage of
gas
this is a couple years ago now and he's
like he's like yeah man
you guys make fun of me but i'm the only
one driving my [ __ ] to work you know i'm
like i don't want to hear it
no that's what happened when gas prices
were low i would get gay bashed
when gas prices came up people would be
coming over like like pesky
i could give you a ride hey how much is
uh
how do you like that did that thing work
out i was gonna buy it
for the shop car for the loop center
that we owned and he ended up selling it
but
i am i washed it and they took a picture
of me washing it because i talked
i'll never drive this car you know own a
car wash i was like well i'll clean it
up for whatever
well this picture haunts me because it
comes back on your news feeds like do
you remember this
you know and you're like damn it i'll
have to send it i'll never find it i'll
tell you this
i uh you know another car that i think
is the [ __ ] for what it does a smart car
like i look at that thing notice i saved
this to the end you know what i like
about a smart car
this is the californian yeah i think
this is
the uh no no don't disrespect california
this is all the hot rod cultures out
there no i'm from massachusetts
i just look at it like that's what when
i was a kid
a little kid and you had like a go-cart
that's what the [ __ ] you wanted
like what if this little go-kart could
do like 80 miles an hour
and they built one the only reason why
that car sucks
is because there's somebody in an f-350
tailgating you behind
which i can't go any faster which i
totally get
but as far as zipping around la and i
mean the only thing easier to park than
that would be like [ __ ] motorcycles
so
um yeah i don't know i try to i try to
separate
i i don't judge everything on the basis
of a ferrari i just look at like i try
to keep it in the class that it is what
i'm basically saying casey is i think
i'm a better person than you are
okay what it boils down to i'm not his
name
i enjoy the environment i just sent you
that picture did it come through listen
i live near an ocean so at some point i
had to talk down to you because you're
in the middle of the country that's
that's what's done now right
i'm kidding yes um well anyways i
just want to thank you so much for uh we
finally you know been trying i've been
trying to get you on this thing for a
long time so i'm so psyched that you
finally did it thank you for uh
you know letting us all know about what
it is that you do and people out there i
know there's people
wanting to start their own shops stuff
to watch out for especially that part
where you started
and you had all this work but we're
going broke like that that seems like a
hit book to me um this is hard
i mean yeah it is but uh anyway great kc
matthew
caseypaintshop.com is the website
uh he'll paint it if you'll drive it
right that's right
that's basically it all right casey
thank you so much for coming on i really
appreciate it
thank you i'll be there all right we'll
see you are you ready
yep go for it all right everybody look
who's back it's
all zip
recruiter uh hiring can be
difficult especially during these times
uh but if you're a company that is
currently trying to hire you face new
difficulties from safety
uh from safely reopening your doors to
finding the right person for a
specialized role
housewire could relate they needed to
hire an ambitious reporter to cover news
stories on the u.s
mortgage and housing markets so they
turned to zip recruiter
zip
um recruiter smart matching technology
finds
people with the right experience for
your job in fact four out of five
employees who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
and that's how house wiring found
alexandra roja man they're just naming
names on this [ __ ]
alexandra never imagined
she could get a job could get a reporter
job in the midst of covid 19 hiring
that was frozen and the idea of looking
for a job was discouraging
so she created a profile on zed
zip recruiter matched up alexandra to
housewife's reporter job
because her degree and writing skills
were a great fit for the role housewife
received her application only this is
like a reality show
only four hours after they posted the
job and a few weeks later
alexandra started her dream career
ziprecruiter helped
alexandra find the right job and they
helped housewife find the right person
for their roll fast see how zip
rick can help you hire
try to try it now for free at
ziprecruiter.com
all right uh what do we got now we got
legalzoom
you know it's a whole new world out
there man
we're all faced with new challenges if
you need legal help to overcome some of
yours
that's where legalzoom fits in all right
this is very important here
maybe you've been working oh sorry maybe
you've been wondering about the best way
to protect your family
or maybe you're thinking about starting
a business but you don't know the best
way to do it
don't let legal questions hold you back
legalzoom has been dedicated to helping
you with the right solutions for more
than 19 years if you're looking to
protect your family with the will or a
living trust
or you're thinking about the right way
to stay out of business
uh with the dba llc non-profit or more
legalzooms got you covered
it's easy to get started online and if
you need guidance their network of
attorneys
can provide advice to ensure you make
the right choices
and since legalzoom isn't a law firm uh
you won't have to leave your home
and you won't get charged by the hour
visit legalzoom.com today
to take care of some important things
you need to get done that's
legalzoom.com legalzoom
where life meets legal
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast
uh actually it's a special edition
of the monday morning podcast is what i
should be saying uh every once in a
while
i'm graced with the guest and
uh you know so you get an extra episode
this week
all right so that's an extra hour in
your cubicle that you can actually
uh not want to kill yourself and uh
gonna get right to it
my guest this week is uh somebody i've
known i think for about 17 years
i was thinking uh jim florentine jim
florentine yeah man it's good to see you
yeah it's probably ben i mean we didn't
you know we never did too many gigs
together or anything like that
we were always you know you were doing
your thing i was doing mine but you came
up in jersey
and i was uh the suburbs of boston but i
always felt like you guys
uh you norton vos that whole crew even
though vos probably started in the 70s
yeah but i'm just saying it like you
guys kind of had the same thing where
you weren't in new york city like we
both had to like migrate there
um and i feel like when i started coming
i started coming down to new york with
patrice in like 94.95 moved there in
like 95
and um i don't think i saw you when you
had the long hair i think you had your
hair cut by then didn't you
yeah well 92-93 is when me and norton
tried to start it going in new york city
and just you know
one night oh really part of us yeah and
then about 94.95 but whenever kurt
cobain came out like 93
late 94. when he died or when he came
out well no when
when did uh he came out like 96 though
right no
he came out in september of 91 and then
he died in april 94. and i only know
that
because of uh
my love of metal and metal was over and
all of a sudden i thought he was a
douche when i first saw him when he was
doing like making fun of the tap on
solos and that smells like teen spirit
i knew he was making fun of metal and i
just was i thought the guy was a dick
i'm one of the few people who admits
that because everybody see i've talked
about this in the podcast people seem
to like when they bring up that nirvana
album never mind
everybody seems to act like like they
knew that this that there was going to
be this total shift in music and
you know there was something in the air
and all that and it was just
it took i didn't get nirvana until after
in utero
and then i saw him in uh when they did
unplugged
and right as i started to like him uh
kurt killed himself
yeah no i mean i think i was like album
in the beginning you know and you know
what it's weird about that it's like
everyone thinks that that was the album
that changed
i mean it kind of was but it wasn't
their music specifically it was mtv
and radio decided that that metal wasn't
cool anymore
and they were going to stop playing you
know how do they like collectively
like it is amazing that that album came
out and the second that came out
it there was like all of a sudden all
the bands i was watching
weren't on mtv anymore i remember even
madonna was bitching
uh she had some [ __ ] catty little
interview with kurt loder
and uh he's like yeah you haven't made
uh too many videos off of this album she
goes why should i make him you guys
don't show him any you don't show my
videos anymore
and he and uh she kind of went right at
him and then
mtv like a bunch of [ __ ] started
showing her videos like right after that
like i would have been like yeah well
[ __ ] you you're old now
yeah absolutely but no what happened was
they um
you know and then pearl jam came about
the same time right they just
mtv basically decided what what was
popular and then and then every radio as
soon as
they started playing nirvana and pearl
jam and it was the hot the new video
every radio program across the country
goes okay that's what we got to play now
and they just totally discarded the
metal
so why does that happen though like they
have like some [ __ ]
bilderberg group of like radio stations
like they have like a conference
yeah you know it's just one guy like you
know one big program or probably the guy
from [ __ ] z 100 in new york
right whatever that douche bag was and
he started going oh you know what
nirvana is the newer pearl jam and then
everybody
other radio station what's new york
playing and la's playing this or we got
to play it and then
they just copy it's just you know it's
like the tv business one show successful
on the
try to put 50 more out like yeah because
i remember that that was uh overnight i
know i'm old now so i don't pay
attention to like music
changing right but that's the last time
i remember was just like i thought it
was going to be like head bangers ball
and [ __ ] you remember the top uh what
was that thing that that guy
who tried to dress like a headbanger but
wasn't the guy was from like [ __ ]
sweden i'm that european guy with the
blonde hair
adam curry yeah yeah no no is he not
when he
was that one of the original guys no he
was like the guy that wore the leather
jacket he had the fluffed
uh like blonde yeah yeah that was adam
carrick yeah yeah yeah so he used to
host that top ten thing and i swear to
god
like the top ten was like eight metal
videos and like maybe
janet jackson would slip in or [ __ ]
jody watley
there'd be like one r b thing and uh and
then some like new kids on the block
thing or something like that and then
the rest of it
was all [ __ ] guns and roses skid row
and i thought it was gonna be like that
forever obviously i mean i was a young
kid
i didn't know that music changed i
thought disco sucked but
i have to bring this up i talked to you
right right before we started this thing
was how i
was trashing a lot of the metal videos
that i saw
i came home one night like uh late at
night and i put on like vh1 and i was
astounded
and how bad some of the music was that i
listened to
in some of the videos like there was one
quiet riot one where they actually sort
of wrapped or did some sort of
scratching
before their song came on i want to say
it was about russia
i don't know i don't know that one it
must have been later one
yeah no i don't know i combined [ __ ] but
i like i don't know so people think
i don't know that i don't like metal i
like it but i like i don't look at it
like
like with like uh just you know with
blinders on no no i mean
if you look back at those videos because
the vh1 classic plays them all time
metal mania i'll play like four hours
i'm did a [ __ ]
awful yeah ronnie james dio you know i
love ronnie he was a great dude and you
know i personally know but walking
around with a sword and
fighting these demons and you know
saying come on you're
you're playing a meta and he's going
through the woods and he's saying dude
when they were out though when you were
a kid you thought they were sick you're
like did you see the new deal video dude
it's [ __ ] unreal yeah
yeah and then you know they always and
then the other like the poisons always
had the hot chick in there the warrants
always had that it's like holy [ __ ] do
you see that hot man is she [ __ ] hot
and you look back she's like she's not
that hot
no no they were awful they were awful
it's funny because we're gonna have uh
nan and nancy
nancy nancy and anne wilson from hart on
our show in a couple days and me and my
friend eddie were talking how we used to
jerk off to
nancy wilson because she had the big
tits and she had the cleavage
you know those you know now is that the
red head of them yeah yeah yeah
yeah they always had the tits out you
know they had to in the 80s and i was
like that was that's what i jerked off
to in 87
88. do you remember when the other one
got real fat and they tried to shoot
around it by doing like an extreme
close-up of her face
yeah and they tried everything that they
could she went she was sort of like the
original like fat chick from like wilson
phillips
yeah yeah that she had like the i don't
like when people get fat
and they complain about this business
and the pressure
to stay in shape it's like you want to
be on a stage
and eat whatever you want and it doesn't
work that way you have you have to come
into this business
of fat [ __ ] like if you come in that way
like hey it's the fat [ __ ]
then you're all good but you can't
become fat
in this business you're gonna you know
you're gonna get trashed
yeah absolutely i mean yeah she was she
was hot in the 70s
yeah she was you know yeah she
definitely put on i was i was reading an
article on them they were saying how
the record company was so afraid to tell
her she has to lose weight that she was
the record company you know brought the
band in without her and said please
talk to her because we we wouldn't want
to piss her off but she has to lose
weight right and the band went to when
she got so [ __ ] pissed she left the
record company at the time i think it
was capital she's like [ __ ] them
yeah and she was wearing like oh they
used to wear all like that leather and
stuff
it's not a good thing there's been a
couple people who got fat george
thorogood got fat
yeah he still wore those those snakeskin
leather pants i went to some [ __ ]
blues festival and he was there and he
came out with these [ __ ] things dude
he looked like he just had a kid it was
it was
awful and it was like one of those
things where it's like dude you got to
do something wear a button down and some
jeans
and hit the [ __ ] treadmills it's just
one of those if you're like in this
business
absolutely you can't you can't um you
know losing your hair or anything you
know like that's
you know i'm losing mine and i'm just
saying [ __ ] it i'm just letting it go
yeah yeah it start i'm starting to go in
the back and i'm just like uh
i i can't what am i gonna do i'm gonna
scalp the back of my head and then have
that [ __ ] put in the front
i just i this is why i look at it you
know
if i was gonna be the next brad pitt it
would have happened by now i'm [ __ ]
freedom
it's like you're right i'm 44 years old
what am i gonna
[ __ ] be some 50 year old sex symbol
yeah you know i'd rather be the just the
uh i you know dude i do a podcast that
told jokes
i'm good i get right i can make my
[ __ ] rent
i don't need to go there and get my
[ __ ] face yank back and have some
pubes taken from [ __ ] my dick and
stuck on my head i mean
no matter what this business is gonna be
finished with me at some point
so i've kind of made a rule that i am to
try to look like a [ __ ] human being
at the end of this um you know unless uh
unless they so get like
the facelift down if they get it down
where you actually can still look like a
human being like
right i've been talking lately on stage
have you seen that that cinegenics or
whatever it is you know like those
yeah yeah these guys i i looked that
[ __ ] up like those old guys who were
shredded it's [ __ ] they are on hgh
that's what i thought it was yeah
they're they're on they're on [ __ ]
that's why that guy has that tone like
he wants to fight his kids
right in better shape than my kids you
feel like he's getting ready to snap
so like don't they say that that's like
cancer causing like
the the hgh so like those guys there's
this first wave of old guys
they're probably gonna [ __ ] something
bad's gonna happen in four to five years
and then they'll use them as guinea pigs
so i figure by the time we get there
it's like roy snow like back when we
were kids roy's you know would shrink
your balls up you got [ __ ] titties
it was horrible and you [ __ ] died and
now but now they got that that synthetic
stuff they got the clear they
they just keep making it better so real
quick if they
if they come up with a [ __ ] pill for
a full head of hair
or you know anything or if it just feels
like your head's on fire for a minute i
would do it
but like as far as like scalping the
back of my head there's no [ __ ] way
i'm doing that
yeah i mean yeah i'm on the fence about
that too i mean
yeah i mean there's never been a sex
symbol all of a sudden that 44
no even george clooney made it like 32
or 33 and that was like late
yeah he was old he was already he was
around for 10 years doing little bit
parts and all of a sudden he got er or
whatever and then he became a sex of so
and plus the advantage of kind of being
a mess
is no one really pays attention to your
aging as much as like like if you're in
that
people magazine 50 most beautiful people
people always say the funny [ __ ]
oh my god did you see so and so what
happened to her what happened to him
it's like dude what the [ __ ] happened to
you you think you think you're like
you know under glass not aging right
yeah you're right you're right i just
i i try to keep it as low maintenance as
possible jeans and a t-shirt and [ __ ]
whatever and i'm gonna brush my hair i
don't [ __ ] do anything you know
i don't want makeup on when i go on tv i
don't no i don't want him no he had that
guy
seriously i got i don't for watching you
know what's funny i like how we're
acting
like being a sex symbol is actually an
option for us yeah i know like
we're going no we don't want that yeah
if we just took care of ourselves a
little better
well speaking but look when i was in the
late 80s early 90s when i had long hair
i took like bon jovi's whatever style he
had or
david coverdale from white snake and i i
got a lot of [ __ ] ass so i was
almost considered a sex symbol back then
even though i wasn't
but you can be a local sex symbol well i
was in pennsylvania i was a [ __ ] 12
on a scale of 1 to 10. because they were
still five years behind
the whole like you know long hair thing
so i would do all these gigs out in
pennsylvania and just [ __ ] clean up
that's hilarious do you ever go back
there like is that like your germany
like david hasselhoff do you ever just
go back to pennsylvania do like a
book signing or something no because
once i cut my hair they cut me off
they no longer like it i was over they
were they were mad they're just like
remember when metallica cut their hair
all the half their fans were pissed
yeah they [ __ ] cut their hair with
felicity yeah who cares
oh so that that's going to change their
music so yeah they turned on me
pennsylvania too
just before all my listeners trashed me
for knowing the felicity thing i took an
acting class with a girl who was on the
show there was some show called felicity
and every guy
like 14 year old boy loved this girl
felicity and then she
she got her uh uh this you know i'm
gonna play softball now haircut
and and the whole [ __ ] show tanked
and this actress was a little bit older
so she was she came in just
bitching one day because she finally had
a [ __ ] regular gig or something like
that she wasn't one of the main people
uh but you know she was on like three
four [ __ ] episodes a season and this
chick cut her hair and like a hundred
people lost their jobs
well yeah so that's how i know what
people
could see i could see that i remember
when cheryl i always thought show a crow
was hot
i always heard something and then
remember when she came out with that
[ __ ] soccer mom hairdo for like a
year
she cut all off and it was really short
it [ __ ] she looked terrible you can't
do that you can't
as a woman if you come into the business
[ __ ] hot or whatever you have to
look that way
the whole it's the same thing it's the
same thing like uh
um even as a guy as a guy if you're
coming in and you know you're all
shredded and you have abs and that type
of [ __ ] you got it you have to
you can't get fat you know what i mean
unless you i guess you're playing some
uh
trying to win an oscar but you can but
you then have to go back and lose the
[ __ ] yeah
absolutely that's the thing dude so if i
look like [ __ ]
ron howard you know it's
i basically i realized now that i'm
losing my hair that i'm gonna look like
him my whole [ __ ] life which is
really disappointing
um that you know there's no uh
you know there's no [ __ ] problem but
you're you're 44 i mean you'll
you know when do you think it might the
career might start slowing down
do you think he got to at least 50 50 i
think when you think it's going to start
um dude what i'm doing right if i just
do if i make money off my podcast and i
make and i just keep putting out
specials every couple of years i'm
[ __ ] good like my
free time is priceless like
uh you know you get into this [ __ ]
business and they start going i want you
know like
you just think that you want a tv show
and then i don't know you get kind of
close to it and uh i mean i don't know
like your show
i if i was gonna do one i like a show
like yours that metal show where
it's like it's that's taped in pretty
much real time right maybe a couple of
pickups or whatever
in real time for people not in show
business here it's just basically
you know 30 minute show is shot in like
30 minutes
and maybe if there's a couple of flubs
if you said the name of an album wrong
you might have to go back and re-record
that but
like uh those one-hour one cameras
those are that's 12 hours a day like
five
six days i think was it five days a week
they should they shoot an episode every
four days and they start the next one
friday and you just keep going
i don't know i guess it's like three
months of your life right i'm too
uh i i would rather just go slug it out
in a strip mall
and just make money that way and then
just come back here and then [ __ ]
play guitar or [ __ ] around absolutely
man
um i love taking time off you know
you got to do it absolutely just you
know because i was always like even i'd
work on holidays i'd feel like if i
didn't get on stage in two days i'm like
what am i doing man [ __ ] i'm gonna be
rusty [ __ ] i'm
what am i what am i doing my career
everybody's passing me by and now i'm
like
gives a [ __ ] yeah no no you gotta like
when you guys tape
like you're out here right now in los
angeles to tape uh
like how many of that we're only doing
we're doing six episodes this we already
taped two a few months ago whatever
they're gonna put them
but yeah we take two episodes in a day
we take from three to seven we knocked
out two
two hour episodes and four hours
basically with like an hour break in
between so we did
awesome yeah we just popped them out i i
notice [ __ ] you know and i mean it's not
like i gotta study it
we got you know guys from iron maiden
and [ __ ] coming on which i've been fans
for years so i just like
i'm just interviewing one of my idols
and there's a you know cameron which is
awesome
jesus christ it's not too much like
you've quietly created you created
the co-creator on this show no but no i
mean i pitched it with uh
you know my buddy well eddie trunk uh
he's a dj in new york and he's been on
for a while
record labels and stuff we became
friends i go on his radio show and we
just you know debate
metal and he goes i'm going to try to
get this as a tv show dude that guy
is on like a whole other level
like he has to be the biggest metal fan
ever
that guy like i like he he takes it all
like really like seriously like i i feel
like if i could get into a bait with
debate with him
and he could actually convince me that
kiss is just as relevant as the beatles
uh yeah he can absolutely i'm seeing i
mean i can sit there like i love ac dc
right uh but i mean they're not on the
same level as the beatles
they're just not you know what i mean
like it's they're just not no no i love
those guys i'm not trying to
no i love any bands or anything i love
those guys to death by the way i thought
that was hilarious where they described
your uh your show at least on wikipedia
they said uh
that that metal show was the uh the
tonight show for ac dc fans yeah
that's the greatest phrase ever who came
up with that i know someone in a review
someone that came to the show and
reviewed it or something because they
wanted the vh1 wanted to say it's
it's the view uh it's a cross between
uh the view head bangers ball and the
view i'm like get that [ __ ] nobody
no one that likes hard rocker metal
watches the view once not don't say that
they go no it's
a successful show and they're like and
they wanted me to say that in interviews
and i would never say it and like they
were getting really pissed like he's got
tell him to say it's a cro like i'm
never saying that what is wrong with
them
just them in general see that's right
when i hear stories like that i just
like how do you just not go
that is the dumbest [ __ ] idea
on the you know what i i just feel like
sometimes they just have to say
something to justify the fact that they
have a desk
because if they if there's if there's
they just want to be like oh it's it's
uh headbangers ball meets the view i
came up with that
that was my contribution to that show
and now i want to go
create something else i guess that's how
they go up i'm really not trying to
sound like a bitter [ __ ] but i am
here
no go you have to because it's like come
on we know like no
i like that fan base when i go to an oz
fest i can go up to 20 000 people do you
watch the view
and the [ __ ] about 19 000 would punch
me in the face yeah if we're even asking
them that
no one would say yes so why are we going
it's a cross between a headbanger as
well and the viewer as soon as the guy
if i saw that because i would tell him i
go if i saw that i go the view i'm not
watching that
and you know what their thought is their
thought is well this is a very male
demographic we got to get the females in
there so then they throw in the view
and and just they can't you know what it
is they can never make enough [ __ ]
money
they're just never making enough they
always have to do it and then they got
to add
some extra [ __ ] thing and then when
it nose dives then they'd put it on you
yeah yeah absolutely and then you would
have to bear that cross
weren't you on that show that was like
the view but you had ozzy on it and
you'd be like
that wasn't the idea you know and the
other person gets to just skate away
i know i've been lucky because um you
know the producer gets it and
you know we fought for what what they
will i think originally they wanted to
be like a rock of ages type thing to
goof on
the 80s medal they wanted us to
basically dress in spandex and put wigs
on and
you know go all that stuff and we're
like absolutely not
we're three [ __ ] guys with no energy
we're not physical we just sit there
and we talk heavy metal but i don't like
i don't we don't make anything bigger
i'm not we're not flashy we don't throw
kicks i gotta admit
i've been real jealous watching some of
the people you've gotten to talk to like
just knowing you have iron maiden iron
maiden is one of my big
like i [ __ ] up that i didn't go see
them i could have seen them on the power
slave tour
i forget what it was my dad was pissed
at me or something i i
[ __ ] up like two weekends before and
somebody had another ticket and it was
like you know i was young enough where i
still had to ask permission
still living at home like 16 17 i was
just like uh
yeah i got to let the old man cool off
and i i can't make that one and uh
i actually think my friends didn't even
make it to the show they got so hammered
my friends were idiots
but uh that's one of the big ones and
you
yeah i saw one time i was flipping
through and i saw uh
you had jason bonham on and uh you know
i'm a
john bonham freak and i met him one time
at guitar center in
somewhere in florida i don't know why he
was in there
he was living down in um uh fort
lauderdale coral springs for like i
think he still lives down there jason
oh okay yeah well i ran into him and and
he was cool as hell he liked comedy
and i got this like you know cell phone
pictures back there was like a flip
camera and they're usually awful somehow
it was [ __ ] great
it was just this awesome picture of me
and jason bonham and then i left the
[ __ ] cell phone
in the goddamn cab on the way to the
airport and i had never
sent it to me uh sent it uh emailed it
to myself or anything so
i was slipping through the [ __ ]
channels dude i'm such a john bonham
like freak that when like
like when i shook jason's hand like i
was thinking like he shook his dad's
hand at some point he had to have you
know like you walk around going hey dad
but it just like
i literally felt like uh i don't know i
was like the biggest fan boy ever so
when i saw that you had them on the show
him on the show it's just like jesus
christ
yeah i mean i i would that guy would
have like had to call security if i
actually got to sit down and ask him
and it would be like 50 million
questions about his dad which he's
probably sick of
answering um i think he um you know he
doesn't mind it though he went out and
did that whole zeppelin thing and
supposedly i heard from a reliable
source there's going to be something
going on with zeppelin
at the end of the year oh is that right
yeah i don't the guy wouldn't say what
he's like a
famous photographer who's really close
with jimmy page well i thought
i thought jason played great uh during
that last reunion that they did for the
head of atlantic records when he died
yeah and what i loved was
uh he just he he was doing like an
amalgam of like studio and live [ __ ] he
heard his dad do
plus he had he had a lot of him in it
like i thought that he he wasn't i mean
that's got to be terrifying
because like zeppelin fans and like
drummers
like um i hate like i look at like
there's a lot of people do like drum
covers on youtube and they'll do a drum
cover of like uh
[ __ ] you know some zeppelin song and
somebody will kill it
and someone would be like good job but
there's only one john bonham it's like
everybody knows that
this guy doesn't think he's [ __ ] john
bonham he just loves the guy
and and it inspired him to learn how to
make play drums and learn how to plays
i've even seen them like jason
jason's bottom who have like you know
him playing drums and he's [ __ ]
killing it and some would be like you
know
yeah but he's nowhere near his dad and
it's like nobody is
right and he he doesn't have a t-shirt
saying i'm really near to my dad
when it comes to drums it's just so
[ __ ] annoying
um and i don't even know why i read the
comments i think i just
read them just to see that just to get
mad of course because
if john was still around and jason john
goes i'm out of zeppelin and they hired
jason to play drums then you go hey you
know
you need his dad back there he's no john
but he's not around what are you gonna
do so [ __ ] just let jason be jason
right which is why i don't mind when
people trash wolfgang van halen i want
michael anthony back there it's [ __ ]
annoying they finally got david lee roth
back in just get michael anthony back in
there
you can never he can they could that
will never happen how does eddie throw
his son out of the band
oh yeah you know what i mean that's the
problem and alex is the uncle
he has to leave he's got to throw his
son out wolfgang has to leave
you know michael's doing the show
michael and sammy are doing our show
this week
oh where are they going to be at would
they tape in our show oh
is that uh oh this week yeah do you want
to come out if you're around you want to
come to the tape and i miss everything
when is it
like why i think it's wednesday
wednesday of course i'm going
okay so it's time for a little
advertising
um all right peoplestamps.com here we go
there are too many
what-ifs when you go to the post office
what if there's traffic
or what if you can't find parking oh
what if there's some smelly sob
holding the door mommy i don't want to
go in there he's smelly
i don't care judy things get smelly in
life
you need to push past this i married
your father this is our situation
get in there and get the stamps right no
one wants to go through that
what if it's closed when you get there
what if you're too dumb to realize the
sun went down
and you don't realize that they're not
in the post office anymore you
understand here
there's a lot of what-ifs with their
limited hours you never know
avoid all that hassle just use
stamps.com
what's that bill what is stamps.com well
i'll tell you you
son of a gun uh stamps.com is basically
bringing the post office into your home
your apartment your flat your duplex
um your tented city well stamps.com
anything you can anything you can do
with the post office you can now do from
the convenience of your own desk
i've done it it's awesome you can buy
and print official us postage using your
own computer
and printer it's great you feel like the
king of the world
uh get exact postage for any letter or
package whenever you need it
right 24 7. unlike the post office
stamps.com
never closes okay and you don't have to
look at somebody's
stupid face when you walk up there you
know when they put that little thing
sorry this window's closed and you want
to beat them with that little sign
um anyways i actually use stamps.com
that's how i send out all of my dvds i
put on a little i'm in a mailroom hat
and i
weigh my dvds and i send them off to a
strip mall near you
so i can then go out dance like a monkey
and hopefully [ __ ] myself out after the
show
and sell the dvds but that's another sad
story
back to the uh the special offer here
right now use my last name
bur b-u-r-r for this special offer it's
a no risk trial
plus 110 dollar bonus offer includes a
digital scale
to weigh your letters and packages up to
fifty five dollars free postage
all right don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything
else click on the radio microphone at
the top of the home page and type in bur
b-u-r-r
stamps.com enter bur and bring the post
office into your world stop going into
their world
all right it's like the end of one of
those nerdy movies when you finally find
a little glowy thing
did i just mess it up at the end there
all right whatever
stamps.com do it if you wanna
something for you evoice everybody
would you like to have a would you like
to have your cell phone ring
but have people not know what your real
number is
you know wouldn't you like to get like
have a cell phone right and only your
friends and family knew the real number
to it
and then you could come up with these
virtual phone numbers that people could
dial that but weren't really your phone
number
but your cell phone would still ring
would you be into that would you be into
a service like evoice that will allow
you to do that
and off these these virtual phone
numbers you could actually uh
you could do conference calling on your
own new business
and on the conference call a feature we
could have actually up to 95 people for
each extension
it's incredible it's basically it's a
business phone number that will
that will ring on your cell phone okay
without anybody knowing your personal
one which gives you the option
of knowing whether it's a business one
or a personal one and not answering it
and whatever it's absolutely perfect
it's an amazing thing
um they offer an entire service where
you can uh
toll-free local managing of outgoing
calls this is all all the
uh this is all the the the what are the
options i can't even think this week uh
mobility
all calls forwarded to a number slash
people don't have to know your
uh your personal phone number virtual
number so long as you have a real number
you can give out
fake numbers but it rings on your own
number and
if you don't pick up on your business uh
your new virtual
um phone number they actually have
professional accents
uh professional uh voice actors
to give you any any sort of like like an
outgoing message like if you want to
give the illusion
that your business is bigger than it is
you have a bunch of employees
one of the options that they have is
that you can actually have like i
personally i would pick some sexy
female voice with like a british accent
just gives your business credibility
you know they'll send you emails with
the text transcription of the voicemail
or not the option is totally yours
uh it's a great way to basically
have all these different business lines
without having to drill a bunch of holes
in the wall in your house
you know you got hello welcome to uh
widget widgets r us or whatever i'm
doing a bad accent you know what i'm
saying you can start the whole freaking
thing so it's email uh e-voice
check it out today do i have a website
here where the hell is it
uh hang on one second let me get this
website
yeah it's evoice dot com there you go
bill you're genius
um once again evoice is your mobile
phone at work it's perfect for business
uh business person on the move uh like
myself i'm actually gonna get one of
these phone numbers just because when i
travel from club to club and all these
uh
different radio stations like my my
phone number gets out there and
and i i get weird phone calls sometimes
you know
i rented a car in chicago at like avis
like three months ago
and then out of nowhere i got it i had
to write down my my [ __ ] cell phone
number
and uh the guy worked at avis called me
up oh actually sent me a text hey saw
your stand up the other day really funny
i'm the guy who rented you the car at
avis which is beyond creepy and i'm a
dude so i can only imagine how that
would make a female so it gives you the
great
like uh privacy options
while you still exist in the business
world um features e-voice offers
includes call forwarding call routing
toll-free 800 numbers auto attendant
um advanced voicemail voicemail to text
or voicemail to email however the hell
you want to do it
uh click on the e-voice banner on
billboard.com on the podcast page or go
to www.evoice
to get your exclusive six-month free
trial
six-month free trial evil yeah e-voice
your mobile phone at work
um that's one of those ideas where i'm
just like that right there is why i'm
not a billionaire
because i just look at that like that
idea was just out there
and uh i just did nothing
why didn't i jump on that like youtube
that's one of those ideas um
anyways but now i'm telling you about
them so you gotta check them out these
guys are great
all right um because i've actually done
half the [ __ ] that they do here and i
paid a [ __ ]
lawyer to do it it cost me a zillion
dollars um
all right if you basically are you
sitting in a cubicle
right now are you wondering why you're
making somebody else's dream come true
why you're working towards that when you
actually have an idea for a business
you know well and you're sitting there
going well i'd love to get myself
incorporated to start my business but
it's going to cost a fortune well
at legalzoom.com if you've been waiting
for the perfect time to start your dream
business
right now is the time to do it you can
incorporate your business
or form an llc at legalzoom.com
starting at just 99 bucks it cost me
like
1500 something like that 700
1500 i can't remember it's a lot of
money they'll do it
for 99 bucks and if you have a family
um you need to make sure that they're
protected legalzoom also
will help you uh make out your last will
and testament for just 69 bucks
that's something that i have to do all
right
i have to make up my last will and
testament which is really
a scary thing for me to do you know
because you're actually dealing with
your own mortality
and considering i just had a dream like
i did last night it freaks me
out but i got to tell you if i'm going
to do it i'm doing it for 69 bucks
um in the past 12 years over 2 million
americans have used legalzoom
for llc's wills trusts trademarks and
more this is basically look if you're
trying to start a business
or if you need a will to protect your
assets this is the place to go
uh you're gonna save hundreds even
thousands of dollars versus going the
traditional route
and i know what you're thinking well
what if i get bogged down what if i
can't figure it out they even have an
attorney to help you
if you need uh if you need help
basically they have
attorneys that you can call in that type
of stuff all right mandatory close
sorry no one's supposed to write the
worst
there's the mandatory close everybody to
this ad start your business to protect
your family today at legalzoom.com you
can also get a special discount
from listening to this podcast make sure
you enter bur
b-u-r-r in the referral box and check
out uh
at checkout for more savings legal zoom
is not a law firm
and self-help services are provided at
your
direction all right so that's the deal
there it is you want to start your
business you want to be incorporated
that is the cheapest most efficient way
to do it
uh i wish they were around back when i
got incorporated could have saved myself
hundreds of dollars
so there you go legalzoom
i [ __ ] miss everything dude and then
we got steve harris taping that same day
too from me of course you do
why wouldn't you why wouldn't you and
then they're raffling off a uh
john bonham drum kit yeah yeah
paige and john paul jones are coming in
on thursday can you make that
ah you know he's got some insane stories
but isn't it
in a uh is it in a metal band is steve
gorman from uh the black crows i did his
podcast
yeah if you ever i don't know if you
know i'm sure you would tell me about
him oh my god
he's got some great and i'm not gonna
tell any of them i'll tell them to you
when we're off just to give you a just
to some of the stories but i mean i
don't know what he wants out there plus
he he lived him so you tell him better
but
um how the hell did i get to know him i
think i doing his podcast as i got to
know him and the black crows came and
they were playing the
palladium one night did some epic like
three-hour show like
first half was acoustic then they came
out did the electric stuff was
incredible
and um he's one of those just really
just you know
you know been through it and back and
back again you know so just totally down
to earth
totally cool guy man he would be great i
mean i don't know if black crows are too
uh rolling stone they would fit in
the black crows yeah well i'll tell you
that guy would be
uh a [ __ ] amazing guest if he told
half
the stories or just one or two of them
they just really like uh
you know it's it's you know what it is
as a comedian we have a bunch of stories
but so much of it is solo [ __ ]
and as much as you might not get along
with another comedian
um you don't have to go out on the road
with them and it's just that thing of
like you know i've done a couple of
comedy tours
and it's just like you know there's
always there's the late guy
there's the [ __ ] loud guy there's the
dude who's snoring
you know there's always there's always
and you have to learn how to get along
with those people i don't know how the
[ __ ] these bands do it i don't either
man being on a tour bus for frigging six
months at a time
no and bunks and they all got that
[ __ ] story too like
the second the tour ends like they just
they just all leave in different cars by
then and they don't talk to each other
for like [ __ ] eight months
yeah it's unreal i mean i don't know uh
i i think that's
i would have been with my friends if i
was in my early 20s when you don't
recognize like hey shit's getting out of
control with everybody's relationships
we need to have a sit down here
and you just let it get to that point
where the level of resentment is so high
you don't even give a [ __ ] that you're
playing arenas yeah you're gonna walk
away from that you can't get along with
the bass player does that even doesn't
even make sense right
they um yeah it's speaking of which uh
we got arrow smith coming on the show
this week
of course you do so question who else do
you got that i'm not going to be able to
come into
i finally have a [ __ ] hookup in this
goddamn way well actually while smith
they're going to tape on uh
sunday it's not joe it's not joe and uh
stephen it's the other three brad
tom hamilton and uh joey kramer that's
even cooler
i know we want to say the unsung heroes
of aerosmith yeah that's even cool
i don't want to talk to steven tyler
about [ __ ] american eye at all i
don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean he said he's done
though yeah i know he has done but i'm
just saying i didn't want to revisit
that or any of that crap so we got these
other guys coming out but
there was a point where they weren't
that those step bands always been
fighting for years
there was a point they didn't even play
for two years and they were doing a gig
over and like the buy
and they were getting like five million
dollars to headline this big rock
festival right
and they had to do the gig they weren't
going to cancel it they didn't talk to
tyler for two years
that tyler didn't they didn't even talk
to him before he walked on the stage
he wouldn't even rehearse with them he
didn't you know before that one big show
didn't play
the first time they saw him in two years
is when he walked out when they started
when they opened up with like sweet
emotion
when he hit the microphone that was the
first time they even saw him that's how
much they hated really
yeah he would he didn't fly so then when
they did the show was he still putting
his arm around
yeah he just went up there like nothing
happened but then you saw like six
months later had another gig and [ __ ]
joe knocked them off the stage
they had a plat they had a whole uh
stage going out to the crowd
like a little and and joe freaking
nudged him and he went flying in a crowd
he broke his uh like his arm or
something like that he had to cancel a
tour
and joe's like i do that to him all the
time but you could see he did it on
purpose like you
[ __ ] you made me sit home for two years
that would happen i don't know
because you as a cop just think of of us
as a comment fell off i thought he fell
off the stage and then he got mad
because nobody in the band ran over to
see what he was well that too but if you
watch the youtube video
joe nudges them and he goes like dude
will you do that all the time to each
other but he
he was right on the edge you could see
he [ __ ] did it on purpose
but just imagine that's like sports
right there i know
was it was he going for the head did he
hit him with the shoulder is that an
elbow
he can't get mad the other guys didn't
come to the show's got to keep going
they just kept playing hoping he was
going to crawl back up
wow but just imagine as a comic like say
you know there's three or four of us
touring together right
and then all of a sudden one guy's being
an [ __ ] and doesn't want to do the
tour six months from now and we gotta
sit home for two years and can't play
right that would drive that would drive
me out of my mind and then he goes on
and does like a reality show
yeah i mean joe perry doesn't just join
another band go [ __ ] i gotta get up on
stage
they sit home and do nothing i saw joe
perry project went out i saw them at the
uh the house of blues
oh yeah yeah it was cool and then like
you know you can't you know when they
come to la all the musicians so many of
them are out here it's like new york
so who came out like slash came out and
a couple other guys
like slashes the [ __ ] he came out and
jammed with the opening band like he
doesn't get he just doesn't
like he just wants to play it was
speaking of torture i mean it must have
been torture for him
having to wait all those years for axel
before he just finally said [ __ ] it i'm
going to do my own thing you know
well that's the thing and people always
ask if we're going to do you know
vaccines they would ever get the
original ban back together first of all
they're not broke
so that's not going to happen they only
do when they're broke axel's ban you
know guns is huge still and over in
europe they perform performed for like
30 000 people
so he's got money slash makes money all
duff's a freaking financial whiz he's
[ __ ] getting
he owns like half a starbucks he's good
and you know stephen the drummer's the
only one that's you know he still has
some money but
you know he could use it izzy who wrote
most of the songs is like a [ __ ]
gypsy
and just lives in a freaking like rv and
just travels across the country so he
doesn't need any money
what band is he into he was doing the
rhythm guitar player in guns of roses
yeah yeah he remember izzy and the juju
hounds was yeah he did a couple solo
you solo records too so they don't need
the money but um
slash even said he goes look he goes i'm
in my [ __ ] 40s now
he goes and if we ever got back together
the original band
and the opening ban got off the stage at
nine o'clock and axel didn't want to go
on
11 30. he went to make those fans wait
he goes i'd walk out the [ __ ] door
on the bus and i'd go i'd be in my bed
by [ __ ] 10 o'clock because i would
never put up with that i'm not gonna sit
i'm not [ __ ] sitting around for two
and a half hours
see that seemed to be the problem is
that they when i i read slash's
autobiography you know
the few books that i read if you ever
saw like a list of the books that i read
it'd be [ __ ] hilarious
there's like a couple of classics kind
of monte cristo
right prince and the popper or some [ __ ]
and then the rest is just all
of course tommy land is one of my
favorite books i mean
hammer the gods i remember reading that
thinking that they really sold their
soul to the devil
right other than yeah just some bad [ __ ]
happens in life sometimes
but uh i i remember reading the slash
one just going like
why are they there's a point in the book
where matt storm finally just goes down
and knocks on his dressing room drawers
or his
his uh trailer he's like get the [ __ ]
out here
the [ __ ] are we doing like it just
seemed like everyone was just sort of
appeasing every demand that he had
i don't know if because they were doing
drugs and stuff and like as long as i
got my little [ __ ] pile of heroin
over here yeah take
take control the name of the band i
don't give a [ __ ] like all that
crazy [ __ ] that he did um oh you
actually got like one of the few like
sit-down interviews with him didn't you
what axel yeah yeah
what was that like it was amazing he's a
good dude man you know he's just
look he's a hermit he's freaking private
he doesn't
want any publicity you know he just like
sits at home and when he feels like
going out and touring he tours and
you know he's a maniac i mean like you
know just that he he has everything has
to be 100
perfect for him to go on stage from to
put a song out that's why it took him so
long
but he's a good dude once a
perfectionist he's a total perfectionist
perfectionist yeah and he just and but
he's got a great sense of humor he's
just a down-to-earth dude but and
there's so many rumors about the guy and
we talked about he goes i don't even he
goes what am i gonna do address a
different rumor every [ __ ] five
minutes about me
you know the london press said like a
year ago said that he just he kills all
the neighbors dogs he
he backs over them with his truck and
then he runs back over him he's like
what am i going to do am i going to go
out and
issue he goes so people think people
think i'm this big as an [ __ ] he goes
whatever i just
how many rumors do you come up with with
that's that's the next one like what
you know he's an alien we already got
that one yeah he runs over the dog
then he runs over him again yeah he runs
him over again jesus he's like so he
goes it just is so much
you know bad [ __ ] about me out there he
goes look and and he addressed the whole
thing about being lady because even as a
kid
my job was right next door and i would
still be a half hour late i'm always
just
running late i'm an airhead when it
comes to that but he goes i like
everything to be perfect
whatever i do and it just takes i know
but i know but being an airhead like i
don't know where my car keys are but
when you hear 80
000 people with their what the [ __ ]
where are you energy or whatever they
perform 230 000 people i think
uh you know i don't know this no there's
got to be something wrong with you like
if you were sitting
backstage in an improv or a theater and
the opening act got off and you're just
sitting back there and you hear the
crowd like what the [ __ ] and you sit
there for an hour and a half like i'm
not ready
i'm not ready no yeah make them wait
another 45 minutes there's no way we do
that in a million years
no i would be so afraid that my that
would be the last time anyone would ever
come to see me
absolutely i won't even do that of
respect for the fans i would do it out
of fear
of going back to what the [ __ ] i used to
have to do you know um speaking of that
how much uh
how much stand up do you get to do like
uh
during the year now with all your your
projects i do like two weekends a month
i'm out you know
do it wrong so you're doing it then yeah
oh yeah yeah i still you know do a funny
bone
you know improv do you still go down to
like the clubs in new york
or anything once in a while i do to
seller
you know killing me man i'm like the i
feel like i'm the only guy
like i go down to the comedy store and
like the the improv
out here and like when i think about all
the guys that i started with
and all that like i don't know like a
lot of them they just don't come around
to the clubs anymore
maybe i need more of a home life you got
a kid now right
yeah i got a kid so that's tough you
know no that totally to do a seller spot
at 12
10. ain't happening and get home you
know and then running late and then i
get home at like 1 30 or two because i
want to hang you know just be a you know
talk and
hang out [ __ ] and you know catch up with
everybody and then
you know he's up at [ __ ] seven yeah
you know what it was amazed at how
norton
could you know once he got the opium
anthony gig i remember
like a few times i sat in for him and i
would go out and try and do stand-up
that night and i was already wiped out
if i had done the show that day
and then try to get up at like you know
5 30 in the morning
like he's been doing that for like what
10 years yeah
12 years that's ridiculous i don't know
how he does he's a maniac
yeah does he sleep during the day how
does he do it yeah he said he takes a
nap during the day but still it's like
you know he hits the early spot you know
he's probably done by like 10 o'clock
he said he goes to bed at like midnight
and gets up at five
five and then his brain is that quick
like he has one of the quickest minds
i i've never gone in there and i've seen
him just like like not on
even jim like if he's tired his brain
always seems like it's like sometimes
sometimes he's better when he's tired
because he's so [ __ ] miserable that
anything will set him off
you know i love what he does i like how
he's into that ufc [ __ ] i like when he
has the guys come in and they do the
holds
they'll like choke him and you hear that
[ __ ] noise he made that stance
somebody put that on a loop i watched
that one time when i was on the road
just [ __ ] laughing my ass off for
like
like just killed like a good 10 minutes
on the road just die and laughing
yeah these guys put them in chokeholds
they friggin uh i was there one day
yeah this guy like uh what did he do he
took it like he kicked him with his shin
like yeah right you right where you get
a charlie horse right
and the look on jim's face was so
priceless because it was like
one of those pains that was so severe
like it it
it it was like a pause before it set in
and then
he literally looked like nauseous right
like he and i remember kenny was upset
too going that
he's like that guy didn't have to hit
him that hard that was [ __ ] he
didn't have to hit him that hard
but it was it was worth it he's a
trooper man he really uh
he is man that guy deserves everything
he has because
i mean that guy would get off a plane on
[ __ ] christmas day and do three spots
at the cellar and two at the comic strip
i'm like dude you could take a day off
yeah i i got spots i got to do
yeah you remember that [ __ ] when we used
to go down when we used to do the food
spots at the cellar
and we would do them and then you'd play
uh everybody would play chess
and just [ __ ] on each other if you
weren't playing chess upstairs at the
olive tree
that you know i love about that thank
god nobody was because i'm so [ __ ]
codependent
if they were all drinkers i would have
been boozing like every night with them
uh but thank god they weren't so
everyone just sat around like like
patrice never drank yeah jim doesn't
drink bobby didn't drink yeah none of
those guys drank
and i remember uh getting into this this
cycle of going down there and doing like
a 12 12 30 you know
david tells always at 12 so i'd be on
after him like 12 45 12 50.
and then you just sit there and you'd
always be like i'm going home early
tonight
i'm going home early next time i was
like four in the morning the amount of
times i took the subway home
used to take the six from astor place
i'd take it up when i was living with
[ __ ] bobby and we'd be getting off
the train
and the sun was coming up and people
were coming out to go to work
and uh it was so [ __ ] because it was
kind of cool
but then also i always felt like a bum
because i used to be like a morning
person had like a paper route and all
that type of [ __ ] and uh
then you get in that awful cycle where
you'd go to bed
at like 7 30 sleep till like three or
four
and then you just wake up and do what
get breakfast and it was time to go down
the [ __ ] cellar again
yeah that's that's a tough i you know i
lived with norton for like four years
and that
that was his schedule i would go to bed
at like two i was never a six o'clock
guy i'd go to
two and get up at 10. he was the guy
that you know at seven in the morning
he'd still be up
and then i have to wake him up at like
six o'clock i'll go dude you got spots
you got the celery
eight o'clock i'd be waking them up at
six o'clock
how long did you live with him like
three probably three years
and and you guys were able you guys
seemed like you'd be able to get along
good absolutely yeah we got along great
man we lived right outside the city we
paid like 300 bucks and
we let we had i had a girlfriend at the
time that lived with us it was 900 bucks
for
rent so we split it three ways 300 bucks
a piece
perfect we were [ __ ] five minutes
away from the gw or the lincoln tunnel
it was beautiful it was a [ __ ] that
was [ __ ] mulled all over the walls
and stuff we didn't care
like 300 bucks it's [ __ ] beautiful i
lived with bobby
and uh we almost killed each other by
the end
and but i i actually learned how to let
[ __ ] go
but bobby has this great thing where
he can get past [ __ ] and i didn't i
didn't come from a school where you got
past [ __ ] it's like you did something to
me
and then we had [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and
then the [ __ ] was over but
i learned through him how to be like all
right dude
you know you don't write somebody off
because they spilled orange juice on
your [ __ ] little kitchen tv
that you had there you know um but
we lived you know you know we lived
three people in a walk through
one bedroom apartment that was one
bedroom and then it was like a sitting
room
right and we actually used that as like
the bedroom
and then in the living room bobby had a
pull-out couch that he slept on
it was ridiculous and the our our
roommate you anytime he brought a chick
back there he always [ __ ] walked
through
like bobby put like shower curtain up it
was [ __ ] hilarious
and the guy always would come [ __ ]
and he'd [ __ ] like try and peek in to
see the chick you were with oh yeah you
know
literally not during but like afterwards
when you're [ __ ] laying there
so one time bobby [ __ ] you know
the dude came walking through so bobby
was naked and he was underneath the
covers
so what he did when the guy was coming
back because when he come back it's the
way you were laying in the bed and he'd
look to see i don't know
see your titties or whatever bobby
pulled the covers off of himself and was
laying there totally naked
and and the dude came walking in and
locked eyes with bobby and bobby's just
like what's up
he never did it again really he never
did it again it was [ __ ]
it was brilliant it was [ __ ]
brilliant it was classic bobby kelly
like you know i would have sat there for
[ __ ]
four days trying to figure out how i'm
going to approach this subject with him
he just got right to the call i'll just
show
him my junk right that'll freak him out
that's fine
and i don't have to say anything it was
it was [ __ ] perfect that's great i
used to have a roommate where his dad
used to come home and want to [ __ ]
look at the girls that were we brought
home oh
yeah he was real creepy right yeah you
know like i think he he
[ __ ] one of his son's girlfriends
after they broke up
wow yeah was he a younger guy
no i mean you know he was like 20 he was
probably like
45 when we were 20 something like that
any bald dude he wasn't good looking at
all or anything like that jesus
yeah so he's always so i remember one
time like we were we only had one
bedroom we're sharing we had these two
girls there and i was on the floor
one he was the son was in the bed with
the other and he comes home and he's
peeking in and he turned the light on he
looked and never forget this
is so funny he looked at the bed and he
couldn't really see and then he looked
in the ground he sort of scrolled and
she was [ __ ] fat
that's what i got and he's like who the
[ __ ] with orca down there i never
he said that he said that yeah what did
the girl do
she i we just put that like ah get out
of here
and we just trying to drown him out he
tried to
we didn't drown out at all because it it
was it was awful
we were we were like i was trying to
hold it in because it was pretty [ __ ]
funny
who's with orca yeah dude you had that
thing yeah i never had like i could
never hook up with somebody i was i
some of my friends they could just hit
anything that [ __ ] moved just for the
numbers i always had there had to be
some sort of
like some sort of attraction uh i
remember a couple times my friend's like
dude what the [ __ ] and i was just like
dude she's
gross and they'd be at least let her
blow you and i was like yeah
so i tried to do that one time ended up
hooking up with this
girl and she was ah she just was [ __ ]
i i don't you ever hook up with a girl
she's like young but she wears like an
old person's perfume
oh the wha it smelled like she was
[ __ ] 80.
she smelled like she was [ __ ] 80 and
that's all i could remember i just
remember banging her doggy style with my
head turned
to the side yeah it was horrific
no that's that's that's bad yeah i went
through that phase for a while but then
it
i needed you know it ought to be quality
but there was times where
because i i had quality dude i never saw
like there were certain guys i saw you
know
they'd bring girls down to the seller i
was never a guy who brought girls down
to the cellar i never like uh
i never trusted like i just feel you're
just bringing them down to the lion's
den
well yeah yeah you know i know
if someone didn't take her they at the
very least you know
i would go down there and take a
pounding some epic [ __ ] pounding i
remember one night patrice was
getting was going after norton and
norton had some girl there and they got
into it a little bit
uh yeah because norton doesn't like that
like if
you know he says something because
patrice will say something that a girl
or something norton doesn't like to get
you know if he perceives which totally
makes sense which totally makes sense
but you know patrice once he saw that
that jim was annoyed
it was [ __ ] hilarious it was really
really fun jim really got mad
and you know of course you know they
squashed it the next [ __ ] day but
when i brought a girl down she said
something stupid while you're sitting at
the table he's trying to be nice and she
just said something
just and i forgot what it was and
patrice just laid into her and the
girl's like i want to go i'm getting
andy why is he so mean
he's an [ __ ] i don't know you know i
thought he was my friend i don't know
why he would say that i mean i'm like
that was [ __ ] funny
you deserved it but i wasn't gonna say
that
no i wouldn't patrice and keith robinson
if they were ever there together
it just was like why would you do that
to yourself like i i didn't have the
skill
to still get laid after parading the
girl
past those two [ __ ] guys because they
were either going to trash her
or they were going to trash me and make
me look like an [ __ ] or even worth i
i really took some epic
epic [ __ ] poundings down there i was
not good at that it took me
i was not good at that game just sitting
there trash people because
the way i learned the game was it was
serious
and you went right for the [ __ ]
jugular like uh bobby has that a little
bit
right um which is why we probably almost
killed each other but when we were
living
together but um i don't know you know
what i wanted to talk about here how far
into the salary 45 minutes by the way
you're a [ __ ] great guest
thank god i appreciate that you know
what i mean there's nothing better than
when somebody comes over and they can
just shoot the [ __ ]
they're the worst you know what somebody
comes there like i imagine on your show
and be like yeah you had one of the
greatest albums
of the 80s what was that like and they
were like oh you know it's nice
yeah it was good it was um you know yeah
it was there were some other ones that
were good too but that was
i know but i mean it's we always discuss
that like lucky that guy eddie eddie
trunk that's
you know one of the hosts he's been in
the business for 30 years so he knows
these guys so before he'll go look
that's this guy's a tough interview
right say much or you can't get much at
him or this guy just talks he'll keep
going and going so we got to cut him off
so he knows
who's been you know i guess you can't
name a name but who's been like
just the toughest like you know who's
tough to interview but a great guy one
of the great
is lemmy from motorhead because he's an
old cranky british guy
[ __ ] i love lemmy he's my favorite when
if when he passes man it's going to be a
[ __ ] sad thing brutal yeah
i saw that documentary on him he's crazy
he's just a legend man but he's he just
gives one word answers and
you know he needs a few cocktails in him
to lighten up and if we're taping at
three in the afternoon he's gonna have a
few jacks in him and
but he just gives a lot of one-word
answers he goes no i don't i didn't like
that album
to me it was terrible and that's his
answer he's not being a dick
right but that's just the way he is so
it's tough to get stuff out of him
he he makes he's a funny dude he gives
me hope that guy
that you can booze at that level
still do you know what i mean 66 years
old
smokes two packs of cigarettes a day
marlboro reds
drinks a bottle at least a bottle of
jack daniels a day and still does you
know crystal meth from time to time
and been doing it for since he was jimi
hendrix rhodey back in the day
so he's been doing it since the early
70s i watched the documentary on him
yeah he just decided to try
like every kind of bourbon or every kind
of scotch i don't know what it was
and he had all of the bottles like on
his windowsill
on the floor going up a bookcase i mean
it looked like
uh like if they ever said hey bill this
is all the whiskey
uh you and your friends drank over the
last 25 years and with him i think he
was just
knocking him out i don't know dude
he's he's he's more hardcore than keith
richards everyone's like keith richards
with the drugs and you know i read
keith's book okay also yeah of course
because that's part of my library
he seemed like he said like basically
you know
i think he has a drink every now and
again but like since basically from 1980
on he's been clean but like
the publicity publicity that he got
when he was doing heroin and getting
arrested and everything like he was
never able to shake that but
he talked about like the way he did coke
he goes you don't sit there and just
keep doing it he's like you do a bump
then you get on with the party or
whatever you know and you don't get
so [ __ ] high you got to keep doing he
seemed like a really like in control
kind of uh user anyways you know what i
mean he didn't like
i mean as a comedian my all the
reference is always like you know
the nuclear holocaust comes you know
cockroaches and keith richards
right the only people he's going to be
shooting heroin into his eye and i just
kept hearing that
and i thought that that's how the guy
was and i guess he wasn't at all yeah i
mean
i think he had like a good 15-year run
from like 65 to 80
where he was just you know progressively
drinking and coke and stuff like that
but then he stopped so he's not really
that
but i mean lemmy's been doing it since
you know
that's unreal well considering also that
betty ford clinic didn't come around to
like what the mid 70s
even probably 80s 80s yeah so like
nobody really knew
like that first you know wave of people
the
the elvises in them you know just people
not knowing that somebody has a problem
and they need like an intervention i
mean
if if you were getting high from 65 to
80 and you figured out
in 80 that's pretty good yeah i think
dude i got a problem with that [ __ ] man
like the level that i like to drink i'm
not an alcoholic but like
you know what stupid joke i'm not an
alcoholic but i drink like one yeah like
i mean i don't
do lemmy level of drinking but like um
i haven't drank in like a month just
took a month off
and uh i don't get like that like oh wow
everything's awesome
and and cl it just makes me want to
every day it's like i'm adding
to the equation of how much i want to
drink like after a week it's like i'd
love like
[ __ ] four beers and then the second
week god i'd love a 12 pack and now it's
just like
i want to drink like lemmy for like like
i have to drink like that and then
realize oh you can't do that then i stop
then you stop i go like cold turkey but
i'm not like
feeding for it i just [ __ ] like it
you know yeah
absolutely man i i was never one of
those uh like my grandparents always had
like a drink at the end of the night you
know i'm like
i'm like there's a comic we never did
that we're like ah you just go to
[ __ ] thank god you guys
didn't because i would have if you guys
did i would have yeah i never did
especially if like i'm if i'm on the
road about the [ __ ] fall autodesk
for three four days yeah i'll have some
beers after the show maybe a couple of
shots but
you know when you're home doing comedy
sets in new york and like now
i would never even think about having a
beer yeah anything thank god but now as
i get older i'm like yeah i have a glass
of wine
have a couple but i don't go that far i
nev that was never my uh
i never had that problem with the
alcohol i always just wanted to get a
little buzz on just so i can wrap with
chicks
right because i had no i was shy right
so if i had a little buzz on i'd [ __ ]
have some balls to go up to him and say
that was my whole thing that's really
why i started drinking that's why i
never get in the drugs so i'd see my
buddies doing coke on friday night we
were waiting to go out there
and they would do coke and they were
just [ __ ] just spend 300 bucks and
just [ __ ] want to talk all night i'm
like let me just have [ __ ] a six-pack
and let's go to the bar
yeah it's like a wrap with chicks what
are you guys doing you're not solving
anything over there
[ __ ] talking about american indians
who gives a [ __ ] you know somebody told
me a
story about patrice recently i nev i
never heard this one
was about he was talking to his mom
about
trying weed he tried it a couple of
times
and was like and then you know tried it
got high and then just got the munchies
and eight and he told his mom he's just
like look
i'm just gonna [ __ ] save the money
that i would have spent on weed
and just go buy the food just [ __ ]
get right to that and it was just
such classic patrice where he was always
analyzing and breaking [ __ ] down
that he didn't have to go through
[ __ ] 20 years like dude i got
i have some friends you know in this
business and outside of this business
who have been
regular users like [ __ ]
getting a bag of weed every [ __ ] week
since we've been like 15 right through
getting married and having kids
and um i mean i guess it's all right if
it doesn't get
in the way of uh your life but you know
i got a couple guys where it's just i
don't know
at some point like i feel like a [ __ ]
the thing with like booze is you can
fool yourself by sitting there drinking
like
you know if you're sitting like in a
parking lot you know shotgunning beers
right it's pretty obvious that you know
you're too old to be doing this
but you put on a sport coat you had a
whiskey bar all of a sudden you feel
like there's this
sophistication to what you're doing it's
like no dude you're getting loaded
you did this outside the worcester
centrum before [ __ ] judas priest
concert you're still doing it
yeah it's just you're putting scotch in
a glass now instead of drinking [ __ ]
beer out of a can in the parking lot you
know
you're trying to class it up a little i
never drank wine i'm like wines for
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'd see my friend what the [ __ ] you
drinking wine no it's good but it's nice
and mellow i'm like [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
queer you are and now in like the last
five years i'm like
i [ __ ] i've been the wine country twice
i'm like this is awesome
i'm always so i hate this bottle i hate
that i like it it's a horrific hangover
but i hate that i like it because to me
wine was it was something that rich
people did
and then it was like the soccer mom
thing like there's so many
soccer moms out there like their running
joke is is if it's after four o'clock or
after five o'clock you don't have a
drinking problem
if you sit down and have that glass of
wine but from what i've heard you know
having kids and that type of [ __ ] you
need a couple of shots you do at the end
of the day but you drink if you drink
you know find some good wine you won't
get a hangover i like
uh barolo my uh my girl's a big wine
wine connoisseur and she knows she was
buying like 15 bottle 20
bottles and i was getting headaches that
go [ __ ] up at the 40 a bottle
and then it's fine you don't get
headaches at all so it's not it doesn't
have to be a hundred dollar bottle but
yeah and the wines of wine is good now i
love it i'm like this is [ __ ] great
it's nice and mellow
and yeah with a meal and i get a little
buzz man that's like i get a little buzz
on like a glass and a half i'm like this
is [ __ ] awesome
you should take me like 15 beers and now
you know what's weird i'm drinking
[ __ ] i'm drinking [ __ ] beers now i
call them
all the micro brews and stuff and i was
never in the night i was like [ __ ]
what are you fagging yeah
drinking what the [ __ ] hell it tastes
like just give me a [ __ ] coors light
give me a bud
stop with this [ __ ] and my my girl and
her whole family drinks all those and i
used to make fun of my [ __ ] [ __ ] beers
no can i even i want a coors light i
want a bud light i'm not drinking a
[ __ ] [ __ ] beer
i don't want to wheat ale summer [ __ ]
you right and now
that's all i drink is that right yeah
i i i go to the micro brews just because
i feel like i'm sticking it to the man
but then i'm like who is the man the guy
who makes budweiser i love that guy
like i'm actually upset that coors light
for the first time ever
outsold budweiser so technically
budweiser isn't the king of american
beers right now
so i've been ordering more budweiser
trying to help them get up and over the
bar
lately you know what i mean yeah i'm
telling you retain their title
those micro brews and all that other
[ __ ] those wheat the ales and stuff they
don't give you hangovers if you i mean
if you have eight or ten they
yeah because it's mo it's pure and i i
never bought that [ __ ] i'm like whatever
and like i'm telling it's you know
it's just better for you i thought the
hangover just came from [ __ ]
you know you get dehydrated with all the
alcohol well that could too but just
you know especially the light beers that
they're doing something to it to make it
light it's not [ __ ] natural
this is such a classic [ __ ] like bar
room
like none of us know we don't know what
the [ __ ] i know we don't know it's like
it's like the alcohol takes out uh
you know yeah the lights process you
[ __ ] drink this some guy was
screaming at me what the [ __ ] you
getting the light for
you know what's the hardest thing when
you're dry to watch as those [ __ ] sam
adams commercials
like they they have to be responsible
for so many people losing their sobriety
when they sit there and they [ __ ]
snort in the hops
like goddamn tony montana they got one
recently the guy literally jumps into
the beer he's like swimming
in beer really and like when you're not
like when i'm drinking i don't even
notice those commercials
but when i'm not drinking and i [ __ ]
see that like i actually get angry
at the people at sam adams like like i
don't know
who who came up with that but they're
making it so [ __ ] appealing
right that uh i don't know that they
they annoy the [ __ ] on me but
we're running out of time here we only
got like uh i mean i guess i can go as
long as i want but i don't want to
[ __ ] uh i i go by the uh the old
showbiz adage of leaving them wanting
more
yeah absolutely but um that's why my
podcast is like 18 minutes 22.
i [ __ ] love your podcast really oh me
and paul version
like we paul versus get does a great
he does a great florentine really i'm
telling you it's it's
uh he got me he's the one who told me
that you would do because i didn't know
you're doing it he's like dude he's like
you got to listen to florentine's pocket
oh by the way hype your podcast what uh
where can people get it it's on itunes
it's comedy metal midgets it's called
jim florentine comedy medal yeah it's on
my website.com
i'm trying to think how he does the
impressions of uh what are you kidding
me
he's garbage he's a joke [ __ ]
[ __ ] brutal yeah i know some guy
tweeted me all day goes dude you sound
so miserable when you start your
podcasts off i'm like yeah i
am i'm [ __ ] yeah i'm [ __ ] sitting
in my office by myself and something
[ __ ] bothers me
like i'm gonna do a podcast about it i'm
[ __ ] i'm yeah i'm angry
how do you think i know you're a big
miami dolphins fan from knowing you're
all these year
years how do you think they're going to
be uh i think they could be pretty good
you know they got new coaches in there
got [ __ ] old man parcells out of
there with his [ __ ] ancient
1980s let's get some big bodies on the
defense defensive offensive line
to stuff to run you meanwhile it's been
a passing league for the last 15 years
you
fat [ __ ] so thank god he's gotten a
[ __ ] overrated piece of [ __ ]
and you know they got a new guy in there
he used to run the green bay offense and
they got that tannehill got a
rookie quarterback and they got a couple
veterans i'm psyched we'll see i mean
look
they might go ten and six nine and seven
probably but you know new england's a
[ __ ] monster are always gonna be
yeah and brady man yeah we got lucky
going to the super bowl and
peyton was out and and the ravens beat
us they just [ __ ] choked
yeah absolutely no i i know and the
patriots in miami's division i got no
problem with them because that's a
well-coached team
and they just [ __ ] they go for the
kill they don't sit on leads when
they're up 27-3 they're still throwing
bombs i love that
well i know what you're going through as
a fan because
uh i had to deal with [ __ ] dan marino
like i just was he just was unbelievable
like to me that guy
is the best quarterback i've like he's
he's the guy that i saw go from the
college to the pro level
and make it look effortless peyton
manning's the a close second yeah
but um you know everybody's all these
guys [ __ ] breaking dan marino's
records now it's because of all the
rules changes that they have maria i
always joke that marina would throw for
5 500 6 000 yards
dude he had nobody he had no running
game one of the one of the things that
that uh
i always talk about on this podcast is
the fact that people give him [ __ ]
that you know he didn't win a super bowl
and it's like the guy had no [ __ ]
defense
you guys had like two white cornerbacks
at one point oh yeah we had the
blackwood brothers
kyle and lyle yeah yeah yeah the brutal
yeah
there was like nine white guys on
defense and two black guys dewey
kuchenberg yeah yeah doug betters and
alicia
you know what it marina was telling me a
story because i became friends and
because i worked on inside the nfl with
him and he's like my ultimate idol he's
the [ __ ] greatest dude ever
mourinho he was tom they had this
coordinator defense coordinator tom
oliver dottie who was the biggest piece
of [ __ ]
he [ __ ] rushed three old white guys
and they would just keep that's why ken
o'brien was a [ __ ] genius against
against my only against miami the guy
was unbelievable
he'd rush three old white guys and they
just leave another guy in the block so
it was six against three
the quarterback had a you know all the
time the world's so anyway he said
before the san francisco
dolphin uh super bowl of 49ers dolphins
oliver dottie in the team meeting did a
d for the defense saturday night before
the super bowl told them look
i don't know what we can we can't stop
this team i don't know what to tell you
i got no plan
and mourinho heard that he goes dude he
goes just he took him outside he goes
lie to him
he goes [ __ ] lie to him and just say
we could we got a plan
because i would do that to my offensive
line all the time you did coming back
and
you could block bruce smith no i can't
you can he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] you can
block him
just [ __ ] get him at his knees
because i knew he couldn't but i gave
the guy encouragement
yeah because i don't think dan marino
hadn't he had no running backs he like
delvin williams tony nathan kareem
abdullah jimmy smith
he had nobody he had one guy carimel do
jabar gained 1200 yards one season he
only had one running back rushed for a
thousand yards in his 17-year career
right and then he also had
he had don schuler who the game had
passed them by
um and then who do you have jimmy
johnson jimmy johnson jimmy johnson
seemed like he wanted him out the door
the second he got jimmy johnson hated
him
right mourinho told me a great story
real quick he said um
that's you know no no we're going to go
long if he hated he [ __ ] know dan
marino
he hated jimmy johnson jimmy johnson was
a dick to him and
there was no reason for it he goes i
bought into his plan but he so anyway he
said that one time he goes you know
coach schuler shula was a coach he goes
i'll tell you he goes shula had a dog
named zonka a [ __ ] bulldog named
zonka that's a [ __ ]
coach he goes jimmy johnson and a little
[ __ ] yorkie
that he would bring on the on the team
planes he goes we're we're trying to
play buffalo in the championship game
he's in
he's in the first seat in the [ __ ]
plane petting fluffy goes how am i gonna
[ __ ] win with a coach that brings a
[ __ ] six-pound yorkie
named fluffy and he's [ __ ] got on his
lap [ __ ] petting the thing
when coach schuller's got zonka that's a
coach
did do you ever talk about uh getting
annoyed with people
talking about him not winning a super
bowl
you know um not really he just said look
you know what it's a team game what am i
gonna do you know you try and that's all
you could do but he
he oh he said everyone brings up the
fake spike play he goes you know because
he works out of new york on cbs he's
always in new york and he's like all
these jet fans going to dan
you know i i hated you back then but i i
do like but that fake spike you killed
us
you know and he's just he goes i just
tell him get over it just get over it
already all right it was freaking 1991.
get over when he did that what did that
do to them didn't knock him out
they were eight and five at the time the
jets they were going they were on a roll
they won like six straight and mourinho
did the fake spike
and they didn't win another game the
rest of the year they went eight and
eight and then they went one in 15 and
actually they went two and 32
after that game what is with [ __ ]
new york and boston i don't know if
anybody else does it they're always into
like
the the that old lady curse
jinx like you didn't win another [ __ ]
game after that because you sucked
that absolutely that's why because you
didn't [ __ ] you weren't ready to play
not because
he like that whole curse of the babe
horseshit yeah it completely ignores
that the ownership of the red sox were
like you know they could have started
the clan
with some of their [ __ ] ideas and
like the whole game changed
once jackie robinson went in they
completely [ __ ] ignored it
and then also let's say that even if
they weren't racist
like what the yankees did going from
you know i mean they got babe ruth uh
they bought him but
they got lou gehrig to joe dimaggio
to mickey mantle that's like it's like
going jordan to jordan to jordan one
[ __ ] franchise did that
and that was the real deal back then
when you had to spot talent and they
came up through your system
and it's just like you're never gonna
see that again
like especially now like i'm not a big
fan of these like these pylon teams i
thought it was really weird that miami
got
like the [ __ ] that they did and it's
like why doesn't anybody [ __ ] on the
lakers
like they do just basically every
[ __ ] year what what my team the
celtics did in 2008 we bought that title
yeah you know but the lakers do it every
[ __ ] year
and and and like kobe's got five
championships one more
uh you know he equals jordan it's like
dude jordan had
luke longley and [ __ ] my listeners
are like bill we've heard this the only
time go [ __ ] yourselves i don't give a
[ __ ]
luke longley and [ __ ] uh bill
cartwright at
center and the only the only big guy
that i remember them signing was [ __ ]
dennis rodman yeah robin they got from
detroit yeah and they had him during his
last three productive [ __ ] years but
like
uh uh scottie pippen that was his guy
that's what they had blonde haired dude
and bj [ __ ] armstrong give me a break
yeah well you're right absolutely i um i
don't know
but also in respect for my listeners my
hatred of the lakers is so [ __ ]
blinding that it really kills any sort
of rational thoughts having said that i
love kobe
i love his mentality i love when he he
doesn't win a championship
and he doesn't just go water skiing
right after he loses he [ __ ] goes
right into the front office
and is like what the [ __ ] yeah get me
some guys
like i mean that i wish everybody would
do that
no absolutely i hate when they [ __ ]
smile after they just lost a game
and they start hugging it out yeah they
start hugging and [ __ ] like that after
hey how's it going
you just at the last second in a [ __ ]
field goal a 47 yarder
and then you're smiling two seconds yeah
somebody's patting them on the head do
we do that as comics if we have a bad
set and [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah i'm gonna sell cds hey once
that was [ __ ] great
yeah i just [ __ ] stay in the back i'm
miserable absolutely not
well let me ask you this last thing i
got to have you on again though i would
love to okay
every guest could be as effortless i'm
telling you i appreciate it
you you damn i rare is another one just
[ __ ] sat down here we just we came
into the house
shot the [ __ ] upstairs came down here
turn on the mic shot the [ __ ] turned it
off walked upstairs it just was seamless
um but i was gonna ask you like this new
thing that hopefully it's just a [ __ ]
little blip actually it already feels
old to talk about is this new thing
where people will film a comedian
at a [ __ ] comedy club and then you
put it up and you have to apologize for
a [ __ ] joke is that the
most insane [ __ ] thing it's [ __ ]
it's it's
it's brutal it is just [ __ ] the big
biggest bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] well
you know i love is is every joke that
they've done it
the crowd in the club is laughing yeah
and then they go
it's sparked outrage it's like where
yeah they're tattletailers they're
[ __ ] little [ __ ]
oh i'm gonna tell you did i say i was
saying i go basically they're coming to
our work
and filming us at a moment that they
think we're doing something wrong
and then giving it to the boss which is
our audience or the public and going
hey do something about this look what
they did yeah that's like imagine i said
imagine if we go into someone's work
tomorrow
and the guy's smoking pot at [ __ ]
lunch time or he's looking at porn or
his computer when he's supposed to doing
his [ __ ]
whatever right doing his [ __ ]
spreadsheet and we go and we film a girl
boss look
he was looking at porn look what are you
gonna do about it
even then i don't think that's a fair
comparison because trying out new
material
is is not smoking weed at work he's
you're doing what you're supposed to be
doing and some of the best bits
come out of doing something edgy and
there is a style there's shock comedy
there's dark comedy there's all that
type of stuff and if you just [ __ ]
sit there
and act like you hired this guy to to
to look people aren't here with my
[ __ ] opinions let me i'm sorry
i was just i said imagine if red fox
and you know with samford in some days
he was a filthy comic i mean disgusting
on stage imagine if people were fil
were recording him and going look listen
to this he wouldn't have a show a show
would have been off the air
i know he's talking about eating some
girl's [ __ ] you know and when no one
talked about that in the [ __ ] early
70s
i don't think people care about would be
if he uh said something about the
president
or if he said like this um
like that whole dane cook joke he was
basically letting people know that this
edition of batman isn't as good as the
other one that's the way i looked at it
that's what i got out of it yeah he just
said it's a shitty movie yeah and then
people get out
he's advocating he isn't
he isn't just i just stay out of the
clubs
you know you know the uh wrestling the
wwe had to apologize
i saw what did that because they made a
joke about what it was such a [ __ ]
great joke this manager is
is talking [ __ ] to the crowd about you
know the
the wrestler that he's managing and he's
going you know so-and-so whatever the
guy's name is he goes he's like kobe
bryant
in a colorado hotel room unstoppable
right it was and he delivered it it's
funny yeah
and he not only did he have to apologize
he had to apologize
to somebody a specific person who wasn't
kobe or the girl right i was mike
something or other i remember you know
reading and passing but it's like it's
getting to the point of like
it's sort of like uh it's ridiculous but
i i look at it like it kind of scares me
because
it seems like uh
if if allowed it's the beginning of like
you're gonna like start
censoring people they they say in the
beginning don't film the comedians
that's another thing too none of these
comics uploaded that [ __ ]
to try to uh reach
anybody else other than who the [ __ ]
they were performing to you know
absolutely and you know what i mean
someone made a good point my friend was
saying he goes you know what i mean
basically what they're doing is they're
it's illegal they're illegally recording
you
because you have to in most states you
have to have permission to record
somebody so they're basically doing is
doing is illegal
by secretly tape recording us right you
know the comedy clubs need to what they
have to do is they have to [ __ ] leave
everybody's phones and cell phones at
the [ __ ]
at the bar before they walk in the room
oh they're not gonna do that they're not
gonna
because they want to turn over the crowd
quicker they don't give a [ __ ] i know
it's too bad someone that
you considered considers an art should
do that go look you're leaving your
[ __ ] phones and every quarters put
them here put them in but i i do notice
though the only people that they ask
to apologize are people who have like
hit tv shows you know
absolutely so i think i think i'm safe i
don't know about you
you know it's vh1 classic it's like a
basic cable it's only in
it's like the nfl network we're only in
40 homes dude you know what i actually
think
i think that they weigh that into
consideration those groups
where they sit there and they go okay
how big is jim florentine
how big is bill how big it oh but this
guy oh this guy's got like you know
whatever like well remember when corolla
made fun of like transgender
people or whatever he goes i don't know
what the hell they are whatever his joke
was he did it on his podcast and they
tried to go after him they go what are
they going to take away his podcast it's
his own podcast
right he's got like dot coms you know
like [ __ ] advertise or whatever
he's he doesn't have oh and so he didn't
know no he didn't apologize they
couldn't do anything
that's perfect he's got his own network
what does he get what are they going to
do
they try perfect he didn't say one word
[ __ ] you
that's perfect i know see that's how i
look at it see that's my thing why
why why do you want to go to the next
level where all of a sudden you have to
start apologizing
for trying out material you know i g
this is the deal if i was sick of doing
the road
i would i i would be uh more apt to want
to go
that that other road but like i don't
know i don't know this is this is
supposed to be about you i'm sitting
here [ __ ] no it's not like it's like
analyzing comics no i i hate it it's
it's the worst thing that can happen to
comedy
it's just worse they would be blind i
want to take chances
well i i just look at it look if you
they there is the style of comedy that
those people who get offended
are looking for exists out there okay
you didn't go to that show you know you
didn't have to click on it you didn't
have to listen to it you chose to listen
to the [ __ ] thing and the guy who
said it didn't choose to film it and
upload it somebody else did so
i i don't know i'm talking in circles
here my mom is 74 years old she's super
religious
right she's just watches like touched by
an angel all day
she's been the two of my shows in 20
years spent the two of my comedy shows
right so i wanted to invite her like six
months ago mom come to us she goes no i
don't like the words that come out of
your mouth you're gonna make me
uncomfortable i go look i'm gonna be
clean tonight so i was working on a
clean set
right and you know what she said she
goes yeah but i don't know about the
other acts on the show
i don't know what they're going to say
so i'm going to stay home that's how
does a 74 year old woman get it
but nobody else does i don't know what
the other racks are going to say so i'm
going to stay home right it makes that
choice she didn't want to go into that
situation but
had she gone down there she knows what
she's getting herself into exactly then
she goes well i made that choice
even though my son wasn't but i went to
a show how does she get it
right does that bother you that she's
only come out twice no no not at all
because i could feel uncomfortable
during the audience
i said penis on tv one time i did george
lopez so i did stand up on it i said
penis and my act and she's like
i i can't you embarrass the family you
have nieces what
they saw that what do you i go mama if i
start
thinking about my [ __ ] ten-year-old
niece when i'm writing jokes my career
is over
now how did you with the mom as
religious as that were you did you rebel
against
brutal yeah it was brutal yeah bro
yeah how bad did she make you dress in
like superman
all that stuff and you know sign me up
for that catholic schools my whole life
you know put in them from oh my god oh
yeah from you know
kindergarten basically at what point
would do were you
uh deciding that this wasn't the road
for you
was it what the priests were saying or
or like what
well probably after like the third
because all my friends are in public
school and i want to hang out with them
i was hanging you know i just hated it
right off the bat and they were like no
it's a better education i'm like how how
is it i got a [ __ ] priest teaching me
math
he doesn't know about [ __ ] math a nun
is teaching me [ __ ] english
you know yeah that's a better education
right you know even in high school my
[ __ ] so what you you went all the way
through until
senior year through senior year wow yeah
i got thrown out of two two schools for
being out of control
and what was that what was that what was
out of control why like they had these
they they were bragging you know they
make the announcements in the morning
oh you know whatever you know so you
have to say a prayer and all that [ __ ]
so they said they
oh we just bought these wrestling maps
we spent a lot of money on them for a
gym class so please take care of them so
[ __ ] my next gym class later that day
i [ __ ] cut them out with razor blades
it was like [ __ ] 3 000 worth of
wrestling mats and i cut the [ __ ]
stage curtains too
why i don't know just because they said
take care of them just
annoying yeah really take care of them
be you know okay fine i'm gonna cut them
up with razor blades
and how did you get caught well they
they didn't know it was me they knew it
was from us
from our class because we were like the
last class of the day like eighth period
or whatever
so they knew it was somebody in our
class and it was only me and two other
[ __ ] derelicts in the class so
they narrowed it down to us three and
they had us in the office every day we
know you did it they'd punch me in the
face smack me pull my hair
stare at the wall yeah and i'm like okay
fine i would stare at the wall i
wouldn't admit it i had to [ __ ] swear
on a bible my
mom took me to a local priest and she
goes i want you to swear in the bible
you didn't do this and i swear in a
bible like
no i didn't do it yeah which is
hilarious if you don't believe in this
[ __ ] yeah i'm like
yeah i'll do that i'll [ __ ] be yeah
give me a whole stack of them yeah
whatever book yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
put slash's book i'll swear on that too
so did you start partying and that stuff
uh you started getting into the weed and
and
drinking probably like 14 or 15. i was
good in sports like baseball i was on
the freshman team i was playing on uh
the soft i played on the uh
the varsity team as a freshman but then
like sophomore year i started getting
their friggin
you played varsity as a freshman yeah
wow yeah i was a lefty pitcher i was
really good
at some point i was a good hitter too i
played first base but then i just
started drinking
and getting into smoking pot and
cigarettes my sophomore year and i would
that was it
so did you did your mom did she my dad
was passed did your mom know you were
doing any of that stuff
not really because i had all the
brothers they were kind of like you know
that that's why i started getting a
medal that would bring him to concerts
at 14 i saw [ __ ] ac dc with bon scott
as a 12 year old kid [ __ ] you yeah
what's at the power age tour
no it was uh it was highway to hell
jesus christ i saw him on for ted nugent
at madison square garden and i saw him
uh ac dc and i forget who else i think
it was def leppard maybe with whitbond
like two times before he died because my
brothers would bring me i was 12 and
they were like 18.
and like oh we want to bring them so i
saw all these
[ __ ] shows so you would go from catholic
school to then going down to one of
those goddamn shows at 12.
yeah partying with your older brothers
yeah they would get me high absolutely
yeah
dude you had a [ __ ] awesome childhood
that was great i mean i was angry
because i was [ __ ] stuck in catholic
school
and [ __ ] like that but yeah i uh but now
it was great absolutely man man all the
brothers who bring home my albums like
oh that loves this black sabbath and his
ted nugent
aerosmith like oh this is [ __ ] great
that's awesome my younger brothers got
that out of me i was second oldest so
they uh you know i didn't know [ __ ] like
my first album was uh
mitch miller sing along with mitch and
the gang okay you shouldn't even know
who they are
they literally i know i know yeah
they're like polka yeah won't you
come home bill bailey like that type of
[ __ ] and then i got aerosmith's greatest
hits
was my first foray into like [ __ ]
real music but
my first concert was uh uh dawkin judas
priest
nice no oh yeah no what yeah that's
right
i was i thought it was a loudness it was
doc and judas priest loudness opened up
for ac dc on
the who made who tour that japanese
heavy metal band
um they're still around are they really
yeah we were going to have the guitar
player play on our show but he had a can
he couldn't get it have you gone out to
go see any
any of uh bands from like that aren't
like huge like the metallicas the ac
dc's that are still playing arenas like
i'll go out to vegas every once in a
while
doing a gig out there and i'll see like
slaughters playing with like
[ __ ] warren a couple other guys have
you gone out to any of those shows
i just saw sebastian bach last night at
nokia oh you did yeah yeah yeah
i is how was it it was great man yeah he
still can sing he's got a good band
behind him and stuff so yeah i always go
see shows now is he going to get
together
uh with skid row he wants to there's one
guy in the band that doesn't want to do
it
the only other guy i can remember if rob
a fuso was yeah he was the drummer yeah
rachel baldwin is the baseline makes
something
guitar player so who doesn't want to do
it
i think rachel the bass player he he
hates sebastian so much that he won't do
it and they got offers like a hundred
grand to do festivals overseas
they could do so what kind of money does
that dude have
rachel i don't know i get he gets to
publish it on those first couple records
you know you've gone wild i remember you
everybody i would think that that would
be trickling down now the kids are just
down like
it is played into sports stadiums and
[ __ ] like that i guess he's got money
coming in
we were watching me and my buddy eddie
last night every time because sebastian
filmed it for a tv show last night or
something so
every time he played a skid row song
like oh rachel can buy another house
because he has to pay for that it goes
to him anytime sebastian does anything
on tv or puts a dvd out
although sebastian write those songs so
rachel did
rachel and snake wrote those songs i
love that his name is rachel yeah i know
why is it rachel i don't know rachel
bolan
i'm not sure he's from europe or
something no he's jeremy
jersey white trash like me all right
what do we got here we're an hour and 20
minutes in and it just keeps getting
more interesting we got to do a part two
at some point
i'm in l.a yeah when are you going to
come out i come out back out in october
back out i was thinking the last time i
think i saw you in l.a i ran into you at
the
the forum for that ac dc concert
remember
one of the greatest shows i've ever seen
in my life yeah we caught it early and
brian's [ __ ] voice sounded great
[ __ ] killer
all right well let's wrap it up here jim
florentine your website is
florentine.com on twitter mr jim
florentine and uh my podcast comedy
metal midgets on itunes
and when can we see uh the next editions
of uh new
season that metal show starts august
11th on vh1 classic h1 classic yeah okay
august 11. it's coming up all right jim
thank you so much for coming by the
podcast thanks bill all right um
amazon.com you guys know the deal if
you're gonna buy something on amazon
not saying you gotta go to billboard.com
click on the podcast page and
click on the banner ad on the right-hand
side the amazon banner ad on the
right-hand side you go
to amazon go ahead and buy something it
doesn't cost you any extra money they
kick me a percentage 10 percent of that
i give to the wounded warriors project
you help support my podcast
and uh the troops who made an
unbelievable sacrifice for us
alright and gamefly.com
wouldn't you love to have 8 000 get
video games at your fingertips sure we
all would
um all the new hits mailed to your home
so if you're sick of paying 65
for the newest games that you or your
kids use for a week and then give
then give gamefly a shot gamefly is
offering my listeners a
free two-disc 15-day trial 23
value go to www.gamefly.com
or the gamefly banner on the on my
podcast page of the website
to redeem the offer there you go
you